We are getting ready to plan some travel for the holidays and so we've started to look on Airbnb We love to stay at an Airbnb because when you travel with children and your family It is nice to have a kitchen. It's nice to have you all in one area Jenna, I got a hot tip for you. What is it? Do you know that you could make money off of your home while you're away on vacation? Tell me more. I will. While you're away, your home could be an Airbnb.
我们正准备为假期做一些旅行计划，所以我们开始在 Airbnb 上查看。我们喜欢住在 Airbnb，因为当你带着孩子和家人旅行时，有一个厨房会很方便。大家能待在同一个区域也很好。珍娜，我有个绝妙的建议给你。是什么？你知道你度假不在家时，可以利用你的房子赚钱吗？多跟我说说。我会的。当你不在家时，你的房子可以成为 Airbnb。
Oh, really? Yeah, think about someone who's frequently traveling. You know? Yeah. While they're away, their home's making them money. That's pretty sweet. I know. That's very Shroot Farms of them. Although Dwight doesn't leave. That's pretty sweet. I know. That's very shrewt farms of them. Although Dwight doesn't
哦，真的吗？是啊，想想那些经常出差的人。你知道吗？是的。当他们不在家时，他们的房子在为他们赚钱。那真是太棒了。我知道。这非常有《办公室》里施鲁特农场的风格。虽然德怀特并没有离开。那真是太棒了。我知道。这非常有施鲁特农场的风格。虽然德怀特并没有
leave. That's true and if he did leave you'd be stuck with Moe's. Yes. Well it sounds like Airbnb is a really practical way to earn some extra money. If you've stayed at an Airbnb wouldn't it be cool to give that experience to others? Your home might be worth more than you think. Find out how much at airbnb.com slash host. The Hot Honey McRisbee is so back at McDonald's. With juicy 100% Canadian raised seasoned chicken, shredded lettuce, crispy jalapenos, and that completely craveable hot honey sauce, it's a sweet heat repeat you don't wanna miss.
离开。那倒是真的，如果他真的离开了，你就只能和莫斯待在一起了。是的。嗯，听起来 Airbnb 确实是一种赚取额外收入的实用方式。如果你住过 Airbnb，把这种体验带给别人不是很酷吗？你的家可能比你想象的更值钱。访问 airbnb.com/host 了解具体价值。麦当劳的 Hot Honey McRisbee 又回来了。配上多汁的 100% 加拿大饲养调味鸡肉、切碎的生菜、脆皮墨西哥辣椒，以及那种让人完全无法抗拒的辣蜂蜜酱，这是一种你绝对不想错过的甜辣美味。
Get your Hot Honey McRisbee today. Available for a limited time, only at McDonald's. Hello and welcome to our second drink of Gay Witch Hunt. This was a very fun episode because Oscar Nunez joined us on this one. And this was the season 3 premiere. That's right. And Kate Flannery sent in an audio clip answering a fan question. Thanks again to both of them for being part of this episode. And Angela, when we first broke this down, we talked about how many deleted scenes there were for this particular episode.
今天就来买你的 Hot Honey McRisbee 吧。限时供应，仅在麦当劳。大家好，欢迎收听我们关于《同性恋猎巫行动》的第二杯饮品节目。这一集非常有趣，因为奥斯卡·努内兹加入了我们。这是第三季的首播集。没错。凯特·弗兰纳里发来了一段音频片段，回答了粉丝的问题。再次感谢他们两位参与这一集。安吉拉，当我们第一次剖析这一集时，我们谈到了这一集有多少删减片段。
We discussed some of them, but you said there were even more. Oh, there are so many more. So I went and rewatched them for this second drink, and I picked a few that we could share and discuss. Oh, great. Yeah. Now I remember you mentioning that there were a bunch
我们讨论了其中一些，但你说还有更多。哦，还有很多很多。所以我回去为这第二杯饮品节目重看了它们，我挑选了一些我们可以分享和讨论的片段。哦，太棒了。是啊。现在我记得你提到过有很多
from the Stanford branch that showed more of the world there. Oh yeah. And I pulled two clips. One just further shows how annoying Andy is gonna be for Jim. Here, you gotta hear it. Hey, big tuna, check these puppies out. My calves are insane.
来自斯坦福分公司的片段，展示了那里更多的世界。哦，是的。我选了两个片段。其中一个进一步展示了安迪对吉姆来说有多烦人。来，你得听听这个。嘿，大金枪鱼，看看这些小家伙。我的小腿简直绝了。
Nice. Yeah. I wear two and a half pound ankle weights on 24 seven. Ask me what my vert is. What is your vert? 26 inches. It's pretty good considering Michael Jordan's is 42. So it's like less than two feet off. Cool. You don't believe me, do you? No, I believe you.
不错。是啊。我 24 小时全天候戴着两磅半的脚踝负重。问问我的垂直弹跳高度是多少。你的垂直弹跳高度是多少？26 英寸。考虑到迈克尔·乔丹的是 42 英寸，这已经很不错了。所以离两英尺还差一点。酷。你不相信我，对吧？不，我相信你。
I don't think you do. Here's a taste, big tuna. Boo-yah! Oh boy. Oh yeah. He's like showing off his calves. He's jumping around the office. All right. The next one is a talking head from Karen, and she shares a little gym snark. Jim is a major kiss-ass, which is probably why I didn't get assistant regional manager.
我不觉得你信。尝尝这个，大金枪鱼。呼！哦，天哪。哦，是的。他就像在炫耀他的小腿。他在办公室里跳来跳去。好了。下一个是凯伦的访谈片段，她分享了一些对吉姆的讽刺。吉姆是个十足的马屁精，这可能就是我没能当上助理区域经理的原因。
A major kiss-ass. Wow. So, yeah, there's a lot more in deleted scenes, but you're starting to see the dynamics of the people there. Well, I was curious about a scene that I did with Steve and if it made it into the deleted scenes. It's where Michael is checking in on Pam after her breakup with Roy. He kind of walks up to her at front reception. It was so much fun to shoot, but it was not in the original episode. It is. It's in deleted scenes and it made it into the Peacock superfan version too.
一个十足的马屁精。哇。所以，是的，删减片段里还有很多内容，但你开始看到那里人们的动态了。嗯，我很好奇我和史蒂夫拍的一场戏是否进入了删减片段。那是迈克尔在帕姆与罗伊分手后去关心她。他走到前台接待处。拍摄那场戏非常有趣，但它没有出现在原版剧集中。它在删减片段里，也进入了 Peacock 的超级粉丝版本。
And Pam has this really sassy talking head right after. Let's hear them both. Okay. Hi honey, you holding up? Yep. I'm painting my new apartment tonight. Oh good. By yourself? Yes. Well hang good. By yourself? Yes. Oh, well hang in there, okay? You know what?
而且帕姆在那之后有一个非常俏皮的访谈片段。让我们听听这两个片段。好的。嗨，亲爱的，你还好吗？嗯。我今晚要粉刷我的新公寓。哦，真好。你自己一个人？是的。嗯，坚持住。你自己一个人？是的。哦，好吧，坚持住，好吗？你知道吗？
You should get one of those big body pillows. That way you wouldn't miss you know who so much. Thanks. Roy. Right. Yeah. What do I think? I think everybody should just stay out
你应该买一个那种大号的身体抱枕。那样你就不会那么想念那个谁了。谢谢。罗伊。对。是啊。我怎么想？我觉得每个人都应该少管
of everybody's personal business. Oh boy. I remembered that scene, but I did not remember that talking head. All right. Well, lastly, but not least, this is my favorite deleted scene for this second drink. So I'll set it up. Jan calls Michael to see if he is actually working. She's like keeping tabs on him. And Michael has a talking head about it.
别人的私事。哦，天哪。我记得那个场景，但我完全不记得那个访谈片段了。好了，最后但同样重要的一点，这是我在这第二杯饮品节目中最喜欢的删减片段。所以我先做个铺垫。简打电话给迈克尔，看他是否真的在工作。她就像在监视他。迈克尔对此有一个访谈片段。
It just cracked me up. Here it is. Okay. What is your goal for after lunch? I will do my job to the best of my abilities. Heaven help us. Specifically. I will do my regional manager job
这让我笑得前仰后合。就是这个。好的。你午饭后的目标是什么？我会尽我所能做好我的工作。老天保佑我们。具体点。我会尽我所能做好我的区域经理工作
to the best of my capabilities. Specifically, Michael. Specifically, Jan, I will make at least 10 phone calls to clients. Yes, I have to begin every day by letting Jan know what I intend to accomplish, and then I have to call her at the end of the day to tell her what I did accomplish. But it's not mandatory. It's something that I wanted to call her at the end of the day to tell her what I did accomplish. But it's not mandatory. It's something that I wanted to do. And so it's voluntary, really,
具体点，迈克尔。具体点，简，我会给客户打至少 10 个电话。是的，我每天开始时都必须让简知道我打算完成什么，然后我必须在一天结束时打电话给她，告诉她我完成了什么。但这并不是强制性的。这是我想在一天结束时打电话给她告诉她我完成了什么。但这并不是强制性的。这是我想做的事情。所以这实际上是自愿的，
even though she makes me. I think she just wants to hear my voice because we're no longer lovers and she's just hurting. But things are going well with Carol. We're no longer lovers and she's just hurting. But things are going well with Carol. I've seen her seven times in the last three months and I'm growing very fond of her kids, Tommy, who I call Tomas, and the little girl.
尽管她强迫我。我想她只是想听听我的声音，因为我们不再是恋人了，她只是在受伤。但我和卡罗尔进展顺利。我们不再是恋人了，她只是在受伤。但我和卡罗尔进展顺利。过去三个月我见过她七次，我越来越喜欢她的孩子们，汤米，我叫他托马斯，还有那个小女孩。
Are you in the toilet, Michael? No. Well, I know sometimes you are and that you wouldn't tell me. So I'm just going to assume that you are and call me back when you're finished. Was he on the toilet? He was not on the toilet. He was in his office. Well, that was hilarious. I loved hearing all those extra tidbits, Ange.
你在厕所吗，迈克尔？没有。嗯，我知道有时候你在，而且你不会告诉我。所以我只是假设你在，等你忙完了再给我回电话。他在厕所吗？他不在厕所。他在他的办公室里。嗯，那太搞笑了。我喜欢听所有这些额外的花絮，安吉。
Yeah, there's some really great deleted scenes on this one. Well, everyone, we hope you enjoyed as much as we did. And now here is our breakdown of Gay Witch Hunt. I'm Jenna Fischer. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office rewatch podcast just for you.
是啊，这一集里有一些非常棒的删减片段。好了，各位，我们希望你们和我们一样喜欢。现在这是我们对《同性恋猎巫行动》的剖析。我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金赛。我们曾一起出演《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为你制作终极《办公室》重温播客。
Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind the scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office ladies. Angela Kinsey. Hi Jenna Fisher. We are on season three of The Office. Can you believe it? Can you believe we've broken down two full seasons and here we are about to start breaking down season three? I can't believe it. I feel like maybe it's because we're having such a good time
每周我们将剖析《办公室》的一集，并提供只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室》女士。安吉拉·金赛。嗨，珍娜·费舍尔。我们正在录制《办公室》第三季。你敢相信吗？你敢相信我们已经剖析了两整季，现在我们要开始剖析第三季了？我简直不敢相信。我觉得也许是因为我们玩得太开心了，
that it just went by so fast. This is season three, episode one, gay witch hunt. This is a pretty big episode because we had some very juicy season two cliffhangers. This episode was written by Greg Daniels and directed by Ken Quapus. And this is kind of significant because Ken Quapus directed the season finale, Casino Night. So it was really great that we had the same director directing all those cliffhangers and then directing all the answers here in our season three opener I think. Yeah I think that's really important you guys
以至于时间过得太快了。这是第三季第一集，《同性恋猎巫行动》。这一集非常重要，因为我们有一些非常精彩的第二季悬念。这一集由格雷格·丹尼尔斯编剧，肯·夸皮斯执导。这很有意义，因为肯·夸皮斯执导了第二季大结局《赌场之夜》。所以能有同一位导演执导所有这些悬念，然后在我们的第三季开篇中执导所有答案，这真的很棒。我想是的。是的，我认为这非常重要，伙计们，
because you know Ken so knew the world and we felt so protected by him as actors and I felt like you and John really had to put yourself out there so then I think it's great that Ken was there with you to sort of get you to the other side of that story. Yeah, there were certain directors that always made me feel particularly safe and protected and free to play around. And that one of those was Ken for sure. Yeah.
因为你知道肯非常了解这个世界，作为演员，我们感到被他保护得很好。我觉得你和约翰真的必须全身心投入，所以我认为肯在那里引导你们走出那个故事的另一面真是太好了。是的，确实有一些导演总是让我感到特别安全、受保护，并且可以自由发挥。肯绝对是其中之一。是啊。
All right, I have a summary for this episode. Here we go. Gay witch hunt. Michael. You didn't ask me if I wanted a summary I didn't you told me to point it out. You gave me such grief in that other podcast about Asking if I should give a summary or asking if I should give fast facts and I got all my head about it So now I'm just doing it. I'm just plowing forward
好了，我为这一集准备了一个总结。我们开始吧。《同性恋猎巫行动》。迈克尔。你没问我是否想要总结。我没问，你让我指出来的。你在另一个播客里因为我问是否应该给个总结或者问是否应该给个快讯而给了我很多难堪，我对此感到很困扰。所以现在我只是在做。我只是在向前推进。
Okay as your BFF now, it just tickles me and delights me if when you say Angela would you like to hear a summary? Alright, Angela, would you like to hear a summary? I really would! Well, in Gay Witch Hunt, Michael gets in trouble for using homosexual slurs at work. This results in an HR nightmare, Toby has to deal with him, and Oscar is reluctantly forced out of the closet. Meanwhile we watch Jim adjust to his new life and new job in Stanford. That was a fantastic summary! All right, let's Angela can I do fast facts? Yeah. Oh
好吧，作为你最好的朋友，如果你说“安吉拉，你想听听总结吗？”，这会让我感到非常开心和愉悦。好吧，安吉拉，你想听听总结吗？我真的很想！嗯，在《同性恋猎巫行动》中，迈克尔因为在工作中使用了同性恋歧视用语而惹上了麻烦。这导致了一场人力资源噩梦，托比不得不处理他，而奥斯卡则被迫不情愿地出柜。与此同时，我们看着吉姆适应他在斯坦福的新生活和新工作。那是一个精彩的总结！好了，安吉拉，我可以讲快讯吗？好的。哦，
yay! Okay, fast fact number one. We've got two big new characters on the show We have Andy Bernard played by Ed Helms and Karen Filippelli played by Rashida Jones Yes, this is a big deal you guys a big deal They're gonna be with us for a while as you know fans of the show and we were really excited Oh, this was so cool. So I had a chance to talk to Ed Helms. Yeah. And I love him. I know. We got on the phone and we chitty chatted about his debut on the office and he told me a bunch of really cool stuff. And I texted with Rashida. So I've got some really great Karen behind the scenes stuff to share with you guys. I love it. All right. So here's what Ed told me. Ed told me that he was a huge fan of the original BBC office and he said not very many people know this. He originally auditioned in New York for the role of Jim. Oh I didn't know that. I mean it makes sense right? It makes sense that he was sort of of that group of actors at the time, but I didn't know that.
耶！好的，快讯第一条。我们剧中有两个重要的新角色。我们有由艾德·赫尔姆斯饰演的安迪·伯纳德，以及由拉什达·琼斯饰演的凯伦·菲利佩利。是的，这可是件大事，伙计们，大事。如你们所知，作为该剧的粉丝，他们会和我们待上一段时间，我们真的很兴奋。哦，这太酷了。所以我有机会和艾德·赫尔姆斯谈了谈。是的。我爱他。我知道。我们通了电话，聊了聊他在《办公室》的首秀，他告诉了我很多非常酷的事情。我还和拉什达发了短信。所以我有一些关于凯伦的非常棒的幕后故事要和你们分享。我喜欢。好了。这就是艾德告诉我的。艾德告诉我，他是原版 BBC《办公室》的超级粉丝，他说没多少人知道这一点。他最初在纽约试镜了吉姆这个角色。哦，我不知道。我的意思是这说得通，对吧？他当时属于那一群演员，这说得通，但我不知道。
He said he didn't get the role, obviously, but he heard that Steve got the lead role of Michael Scott and he was so excited because he had worked with Steve on The Daily Show. Yes. So they were kind of friends. They knew one another. He said this made him so excited for our American version of the show And he watched it and he loved it. And then somewhere near the end of season two, he got a phone call to meet with Greg Daniels and Paul Lieberstein about a new character that they wanted to introduce in season three. He said the meeting went great. He absolutely loved the character of Andy.
他说他显然没得到那个角色，但他听说史蒂夫得到了迈克尔·斯科特的主角，他非常兴奋，因为他曾和史蒂夫在《每日秀》合作过。是的。所以他们算是朋友。他们认识彼此。他说这让他对我们美国版的剧集感到非常兴奋，他看了，而且很喜欢。然后在第二季快结束的时候，他接到一个电话，去见格雷格·丹尼尔斯和保罗·利伯斯坦，谈论他们想在第三季引入的一个新角色。他说会议进行得很顺利。他非常喜欢安迪这个角色。
He also told me that he was originally only asked to do a total of eight episodes on the show because they thought that the Stanford storyline would not necessarily end in a merger and that his character would be finished after Jim returned back to Dunder Mifflin. That was the plan that Jim would eventually return, but this idea that the other Stanford characters would return wasn't quite in the works yet. But he also told me that they weren't totally sure about leaving Jim separated for so long so they would only hire him in two episode chunks. Oh my gosh. Yeah so they said like okay we're gonna probably keep you for eight but we'll only hire
他还告诉我，他最初只被要求在剧中总共出演八集，因为他们认为斯坦福的故事线不一定会以合并结束，而且他的角色会在吉姆回到邓德·米夫林后结束。当时的计划是吉姆最终会回来，但其他斯坦福角色会回来的想法还没有完全成型。但他还告诉我，他们不太确定让吉姆分开这么久，所以他们只会以两集为单位雇佣他。哦，天哪。是啊，所以他们说，好吧，我们可能会留你八集，但我们只会
you for two episodes at a time and he was living in New York at the time. Yeah. So he came out to LA he said he stayed at the Sportsman's Lodge in North Hollywood. You know the Sportsman's Lodge. I do. I do know the Sportsman's Lodge. I mean, how would you describe the Sportsman's Lodge? I would describe the Sportsman's Lodge as sort of like a retro, could maybe be cool, motel. It reminds me of the place where they stay in the movie Vacation when Christie Brinkley jumps in the swimming pool with Clark Griswold. Good talk Russ, good talk.
以两集为单位雇佣你，而且他当时住在纽约。是的。所以他来到洛杉矶，他说他住在北好莱坞的 Sportsman's Lodge。你知道 Sportsman's Lodge 吗？我知道。我确实知道 Sportsman's Lodge。我的意思是，你会怎么形容 Sportsman's Lodge？我会形容 Sportsman's Lodge 就像那种复古的、可能还挺酷的汽车旅馆。它让我想起电影《假期》里他们住的地方，克里斯蒂·布林克利和克拉克·格里斯沃尔德一起跳进游泳池的那里。说得好，拉斯，说得好。
It's a famous old hotel in California. It does have some folklore though, cause like when I got here, I drove past it and I was with like a friend I met in like an acting class and they're like, you know, every day when John Wayne was done on the set, he would go to the bar sportsman's lodge and have a whiskey. I was like, no way. So that people could hunt like ducks and stuff.
这是加州一家著名的老酒店。它确实有一些民间传说，因为我刚到这里时，开车经过它，当时我和我在表演课上认识的一个朋友在一起，他们说，你知道吗，约翰·韦恩每天在片场结束后，都会去 Sportsman's Lodge 的酒吧喝威士忌。我说，不会吧。所以人们可以猎鸭子之类的。
Like there was a whole pond that was part of the sportsman's lodge and they had a diner, a breakfast diner and Angela, there are pictures of John Wayne all over this diner. Didn't we once meet there and have breakfast together? I'm sure we did. Anyway, so that's where Ed was living. That's where Ed was living. He said he rented a convertible, a Sebring. He's pretty sure he basically rented Michael Scott's car because he was like, I'm in California. I'm going to rent a convertible, a Sebring. He's pretty sure he basically rented Michael Scott's car
就像 Sportsman's Lodge 有一个完整的池塘，他们有一家餐馆，一家早餐餐馆，安吉拉，这家餐馆里到处都是约翰·韦恩的照片。我们不是曾经在那里见面吃过早餐吗？我肯定我们吃过。总之，那就是艾德住的地方。那就是艾德住的地方。他说他租了一辆敞篷车，一辆赛百灵。他很确定他基本上租了迈克尔·斯科特的车，因为他当时想，我在加州。我要租一辆敞篷车，一辆赛百灵。他很确定他基本上租了迈克尔·斯科特的车
because he was like, I'm in California. I'm gonna rent a convertible. I just found that so charming. But he said that by about the sixth episode, they came and offered him a deal to stay for the whole rest of the season. And he was really excited and he moved to California. I love that.
因为他当时想，我在加州。我要租一辆敞篷车。我觉得这太迷人了。但他表示，到第六集左右，他们来找他，提供了一份让他留到本季结束的合同。他非常兴奋，搬到了加州。我喜欢这个。
And then Angela, I have a few little more things to share about Ed, but I will sprinkle that into the episode. You sprinkle those in. I'm gonna sprinkle in my Rashida tidbits. I will say that I love Rashida. Jenna, we were so excited to have her on set. We would hang out in your trailer,
然后安吉拉，我还有一些关于艾德的小事要分享，但我会把它们穿插到这一集里。你穿插进去吧。我会穿插我的拉什达花絮。我得说我爱拉什达。珍娜，我们非常兴奋她能来到片场。我们会待在你的拖车里，
like when the guys were playing their Madden football or whatever, we would all hang out in your trailer. And she's just like such an amazing, genuine, smart like woman. I just adore her. Oh, Angela, I feel like we had a huge girl crush on her. We did. We a little bit followed her around
就像当男人们在玩他们的 Madden 橄榄球游戏或者其他什么的时候，我们都会待在你的拖车里。她真的是一个如此令人惊叹、真诚、聪明的女人。我简直崇拜她。哦，安吉拉，我觉得我们当时超级迷她。我们确实迷她。我们有点跟着她转，
because I remember at first, we didn't have any scenes with her and we didn't even see her, but we would see her at the table reads. And then we, I have a picture of us holding our scripts, the three of us and taking our lunch to my trailer. And that's what we did for the first six weeks. We would just see her at the table read, but then we would bring her to my trailer and we would just pepper her with questions because she is like, gosh, she is such a force, right? She's cool. She's really cool and nice.
因为我记得起初，我们和她没有任何对手戏，甚至没怎么见到她，但我们会在剧本朗读会上见到她。然后我们，我有一张我们拿着剧本的照片，我们三个，带着午餐去我的拖车。这就是我们前六周做的事情。我们只会在剧本朗读会上见到她，但之后我们会把她带到我的拖车里，我们会不停地问她问题，因为她，天哪，她真是一个了不起的人，对吧？她很酷。她真的很酷，人也很好。
And you and I, you and I, let's face it, we were kind of dorks growing up. And so we got to hang out with like someone really cool. We're game for sure. She upped our game. Let's move on to fast fact number two. We filmed this episode in late July and over the summer break in early July, we were nominated for an Emmy Award for best comedy series for season two of The Office. Yes. This was such a whirlwind time. We were suddenly like on the map and nominated for this award and it was crazy. Remember how surreal that was?
你和我，你和我，面对现实吧，我们小时候有点书呆子气。所以我们能和像她这样真正酷的人待在一起。我们当然很乐意。她提升了我们的水平。让我们进入快讯第二条。我们在七月下旬拍摄了这一集，在七月初的暑假期间，我们因《办公室》第二季获得了艾美奖最佳喜剧剧集的提名。是的。那是一段旋风般的时光。我们突然就像出现在地图上一样，获得了这个奖项的提名，这太疯狂了。还记得那有多超现实吗？
Yeah, yeah. Well, do you also remember that while we were shooting this episode, we also had to film a promo for the Emmy Awards? They were being hosted by Conan O'Brien and he came to our set one day. Do you remember that? I do and you know Conan and Greg were good friends so we were, you know, excited to have him there and I have a photo. I don't know why it's in black and white, but I sort of went through this phase where I would buy black and white film for my camera, old school camera guys, where you had to buy film. And I have a black and white photo
是啊，是啊。嗯，你还记得我们在拍摄这一集时，还必须为艾美奖拍摄一段宣传片吗？那是柯南·奥布莱恩主持的，有一天他来到了我们的片场。你记得吗？我记得，而且你知道柯南和格雷格是好朋友，所以我们，你知道，很兴奋他能来，我有一张照片。我不知道为什么它是黑白的，但我经历过一个阶段，我会为我的相机买黑白胶卷，老派相机伙计们，你们得买胶卷。我有一张黑白照片
of us all standing around Conan on our set. Well, I looked up this Emmy promo on YouTube and it's there. If you guys wanna look at it, it's actually really funny. So also at this time, the TV show Lost was a really big deal. And so the beginning of this promo is Conan on an airplane that crashes into the water. And then he gets out onto a beach and he runs into cast members from Lost and he's like, I'm hosting the Emmys. I have to get to the Emmys. And then he goes over to the hatch and he opens up the hatch and he gets in.
是我们所有人站在柯南周围，在我们的片场。嗯，我在 YouTube 上查了这个艾美奖宣传片，它就在那里。如果你们想看的话，它其实真的很有趣。当时电视剧《迷失》也是一件大事。所以这个宣传片的开头是柯南在一架坠入水中的飞机上。然后他到了海滩，遇到了《迷失》的演员们，他说，我要主持艾美奖。我必须去参加艾美奖。然后他走到舱口，打开舱口，钻了进去。
But when he comes out of the hatch, he comes out of our ceiling down onto the desks in the office. And then we have this whole scene. And I had this really cool moment where he and I trade looks the way Jim and Pam trade looks and then he does a talking head about the receptionist and how he wishes he could stay but he's got to get to the Emmys. Oh my gosh it like it was so cool it was so cool. I love it. It's really funny because then he just keeps going through like all
但当他从舱口出来时，他从我们的天花板出来，落在了办公室的桌子上。然后我们有了整场戏。我有一个非常酷的时刻，他和我有眼神交流，就像吉姆和帕姆眼神交流那样，然后他做了一个关于接待员的访谈片段，说他希望他能留下来，但他必须去参加艾美奖。哦，天哪，这太酷了，太酷了。我喜欢。这真的很有趣，因为然后他继续穿过所有
the sets of all the different shows that were nominated that year. And that was like, that felt big to be part of some Emmy montage and to be nominated. I just remember there was a big buzz all across the set when we came back to work from the summer. All right, Jenna hit me with a fast fact number three. All right, fast fact number three. So in this episode, you guys know, it opens with Jim no longer working in Scranton.
那一年获得提名的不同剧集的片场。那感觉很大，能成为艾美奖蒙太奇的一部分并获得提名。我只记得当我们暑假回来工作时，整个片场都非常兴奋。好了，珍娜，给我讲讲快讯第三条。好的，快讯第三条。所以在这集里，你们知道，开头是吉姆不再在斯克兰顿工作了。
He still works for Dunder Mifflin, but he's working at the Stamford branch now in Connecticut. We got a lot of questions about the Stamford branch. Where were the Stamford branch scenes actually filmed? And then can you describe how things were filmed with these two different offices and the fact that John wasn't working with you guys for a bunch of episodes? Did he film in the same location? Did he miss you guys? Did you miss him? Give us all the details please! Thank you! That's a good question! Yes! Well I'll say the Stanford branch was over on our warehouse set. It was just in that other building. We had two big sound stages, and one sound stage was completely dedicated
他仍然为邓德·米夫林工作，但他现在在康涅狄格州的斯坦福分公司工作。我们收到了很多关于斯坦福分公司的问题。斯坦福分公司的场景实际上是在哪里拍摄的？然后你能描述一下这两个不同的办公室是如何拍摄的，以及约翰在好几集里没有和你们一起工作的事实吗？他在同一个地点拍摄吗？他想念你们吗？你们想念他吗？请给我们所有细节！谢谢！这是个好问题！是的！嗯，我会说斯坦福分公司是在我们的仓库片场。它就在那栋楼里。我们有两个大摄影棚，一个摄影棚完全致力于
to the Scranton branch, and the other sound stage was our warehouse set and also what we called our swing set. So anytime we had to build, for example, the New York offices, they had a section of the warehouse that they could put up the New York offices, and then they would take them down. And then like when Pam goes to the hospital and has her baby or when Angela and Oscar move in together, that's where they put Oscar's apartment. That's where they put the hospital. Right.
斯克兰顿分公司，另一个摄影棚是我们的仓库片场，也是我们所谓的“摇摆片场”。所以任何时候我们需要搭建，例如，纽约办公室，他们有一部分仓库可以搭建纽约办公室，然后他们会拆掉。然后就像帕姆去医院生孩子，或者安吉拉和奥斯卡搬到一起住时，那就是他们放奥斯卡公寓的地方。那就是他们放医院的地方。对。
It was the little swing set area. And so that's where Stanford was built. And I remember when they built the Stanford set. I remember us being like, holy crap, look how like fancy it is. It looked more modern, a little bit more sleek. I was like, is Dunder Mifflin like the old branch? Like Stanford looks a little fancy, fancy Stanford. I know. I looked at, you know, I love to look at the backdrops that are out our fake windows. Yeah. Jim talks about the view in Stanford and it's great. Like they're clearly up in like this big high rise building.
那是那个小小的摇摆片场区域。所以斯坦福就是在那儿搭建的。我记得当他们搭建斯坦福片场时。我记得我们当时想，天哪，看看它有多高级。它看起来更现代，更时尚一点。我当时想，邓德·米夫林是旧分公司吗？斯坦福看起来有点高级，高级斯坦福。我知道。我看了，你知道我喜欢看我们假窗户外的背景。是的。吉姆谈到了斯坦福的风景，这很棒。就像他们显然是在那种高层建筑里。
Yeah. It's really quite nice out that window. And all their desks are new and the desk chairs are new and the lamps, it's like, Stanford's nicer. Well, I did trade some emails with Kent Sabornak Kentopedia. and he said that when we got this order for season three, we got a little more money in our budget. Oh, did we?
是的。窗外真的很不错。他们所有的桌子都是新的，办公椅是新的，灯也是，就像，斯坦福更好。嗯，我确实和肯特·萨博纳克（Kentopedia）交换了一些电子邮件，他说当我们收到第三季的订单时，我们的预算多了一点钱。哦，是吗？
Yes. And Aaron Carrington Smith wrote in to say, it really seems like starting in season three, the show branches out. We go to Stanford, but you guys also film a lot more outside of the actual office. Was that a conscious decision? Kent told me we were able to do that because we got this bump in our budget. You're gonna see a lot more episodes where we go on location and they were able to build a really nice Stanford branch all because we have a little bit more money to work with
是的。亚伦·卡林顿·史密斯写信说，看起来从第三季开始，剧集就开始扩展了。我们去了斯坦福，但你们在办公室外也拍摄了很多。这是一个有意识的决定吗？肯特告诉我，我们能够这样做是因为我们的预算增加了。你们会看到更多我们去外景拍摄的剧集，他们能够搭建一个非常漂亮的斯坦福分公司，全都是因为我们有更多的钱可以使用，
now that we were Emmy nominated and all. Emmy nominated and had a big movie star on set. We got a little bit more coin guys so we could travel. And then as far as John, I remember it was super weird that we didn't have him with us for like six or eight weeks. Yeah it was weird and I remember like if we would run into him for whatever reason maybe he came for a wardrobe fitting and we were at lunch or something, we'd be like, what's it like over there? How is everybody? Is everyone nice? Like, what's it like? Like as if he truly had moved away. I remember that too. And he was so super gushy about Ed and Rashida and working over on the
现在我们获得了艾美奖提名等等。获得了艾美奖提名，片场还有一位大电影明星。我们多了一点钱，伙计们，所以我们可以旅行。至于约翰，我记得我们有六到八周没有他，这超级奇怪。是的，这很奇怪，我记得如果我们因为什么原因遇到他，也许他来试装，我们在吃午饭什么的，我们会问，那边怎么样？每个人都好吗？每个人都好吗？就像，那边怎么样？就像他真的搬走了一样。我也记得那个。他对于艾德和拉什达以及在斯坦福片场工作感到非常兴奋。
Stanford set. He was, he seemed like he was having the best time. And again, I think I had a little FOMO. I was like, well, what's happening over in Stanford? Yeah. Why is it so great over there? And then when we had table reads and they were all there, they had like inside jokes. And I'm like, what the heck? What's that inside joke? Day, exactly. Big brother, kid sister.
他看起来玩得很开心。再说一次，我想我有点 FOMO（错失恐惧症）。我当时想，好吧，斯坦福那边发生了什么？是的。为什么那边那么好？然后当我们在剧本朗读会上，他们都在那里时，他们有那种内部笑话。我当时想，搞什么鬼？那个内部笑话是什么？天哪，没错。大哥，小妹。
Yeah. Don't do that with anyone else, buddy. I totally remember all of that. And so they would shoot the Stanford branch like one or two days a week, and we would have off, and then we would shoot over in the Scranton side for the rest of the week. And we really did not see each other except for those table reads or those little run-ins.
是的。别和别人那样做，伙计。我完全记得所有这些。所以他们会每周拍摄一两天斯坦福分公司，我们休息，然后我们会在一周剩下的时间里在斯克兰顿那边拍摄。除了那些剧本朗读会或那些小小的偶遇，我们真的没有见到彼此。
Yeah. So crazy. It was Carlisle, but it built the tension. I think it was good, especially for Jim and Pam because, you know, you guys, I think then brought that time apart back on screen together. Does that make sense? Oh, Angela, I completely used all of my feelings with John being over on that other set to the character of Pam.
是的。太疯狂了。那是卡莱尔，但这建立了紧张感。我认为这很好，特别是对于吉姆和帕姆，因为，你知道，你们，我认为然后把那段分开的时间带回了屏幕上。这有意义吗？哦，安吉拉，我完全把我对约翰在那个片场的所有感受都用到了帕姆这个角色上。
Because you really became closest with the people who you had the most scenes with because you had to spend so much downtime with them. And for those whole first two years of the show, I was paired with John so often. He really was my buddy, you know? And I spent a lot of time with him and now he was just gone. And again, I can't stress it enough.
因为你确实和你对手戏最多的人变得最亲近，因为你必须和他们花很多停机时间。在剧集的前两年，我经常和约翰搭档。他真的是我的伙伴，你知道吗？我花了很多时间和他在一起，现在他走了。再说一次，我怎么强调都不为过。
This was before smartphones. So it wasn't like after this summer break, we had been, we weren't texting. You didn't text anyone, you guys. No, you didn't. There was no texting. You weren't like really in touch. And so here we were back from summer break,
这是在智能手机出现之前。所以不像暑假过后，我们一直在发短信，你们知道，你们没有给任何人发短信。不，你们没有。没有短信。你们并没有真正保持联系。所以我们暑假回来，
but I didn't have my work buddy. He was like off on some other set. And so I did have like all that, like FOMO and all that, like, what's up. What's up over there? Yeah. What's up over there? So when they came back, I just used it for my character. Well, those are good. Fast facts, lady.
但我没有我的工作伙伴。他就像在另一个片场。所以我确实有那种，那种 FOMO，还有那种，那边怎么样。那边怎么样？是的。那边怎么样？所以当他们回来时，我就把它用在了我的角色上。嗯，那些是很好的快讯，女士。
Those are real good. I'm excited to get into this episode because I feel like we both have some behind the scenes stuff. I know you're holding out on me, lady. I know you probably have some Kintapedia. And I have some stuff too. I talked to some folks. So should we take a break and then dive in? Let's take a break and then we'll dive into Gay Witch Hunt.
那些真的很好。我很兴奋能进入这一集，因为我觉得我们俩都有一些幕后故事。我知道你在对我隐瞒，女士。我知道你可能有一些肯特百科。我也有一些东西。我和一些人谈过。所以我们应该休息一下，然后深入探讨吗？让我们休息一下，然后我们将深入探讨《同性恋猎巫行动》。
This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. I just had a visit with my mom and I was kind of thinking about all the ways that she has really informed my life as an adult. And one of the things that I really admire about her is that she was always willing to ask for help when she needed it. For advocating for herself. Yeah. Well you know mental health awareness is growing now but there's still progress to be made. 26% of Americans who participated in a recent survey say they have avoided seeking mental health support due to
本节目由 BetterHelp 赞助。我刚和我妈妈见过面，我一直在思考她作为成年人如何真正影响了我的生活。我真正钦佩她的一点是，她总是愿意在需要时寻求帮助。为自己辩护。是的。嗯，你知道心理健康意识现在正在增长，但仍有进展要做。在最近的一项调查中，26% 的美国参与者表示他们避免寻求心理健康支持，因为
fear of judgment. Well this Mental Health Awareness Month let's encourage everyone to take care of their well-being and break the stigma. BetterHelp is fully online. It's making therapy affordable and convenient, serving over 5 million people worldwide. And you can easily switch therapists anytime at no cost. We're all better with help. Visit betterhelp.com slash office ladies today to get 10% off your first month. That's betterhelp, H-E-L-P dot com slash office ladies today to get 10% off your first month. That's better help. H e l p dot com slash office ladies.
害怕被评判。嗯，在这个心理健康意识月，让我们鼓励每个人照顾好自己的幸福，打破污名。BetterHelp 完全在线。它让治疗变得负担得起且方便，为全球超过 500 万人提供服务。你可以随时免费更换治疗师。我们有了帮助会更好。今天访问 betterhelp.com/office ladies，首次购买可享受 10% 的折扣。那是 betterhelp, H-E-L-P dot com slash office ladies，今天首次购买可享受 10% 的折扣。那是 better help. H e l p dot com slash office ladies。
Hey, it's Morgan Absher and I'm Caitlin Moore, and we're the host of the crime house original podcast clues. Every Wednesday we sneak past the crime scene tape and open a new case file for some of the most gripping true crime cases. While Caitlin pieces together the timelines and breaks down the hard facts of these cases, I'll be diving into the theories and pulling out the threads that may or may not add up. From serial killers to shocking murders, Clues dives into all the forensic details and brilliant sleuthing that went into the world's most infamous cases.
嘿，我是摩根·阿布舍，我是凯特琳·摩尔，我们是犯罪屋原创播客《线索》的主持人。每周三，我们都会溜过犯罪现场警戒线，打开一个新的案件档案，处理一些最引人入胜的真实犯罪案件。当凯特琳拼凑时间线并剖析这些案件的硬事实时，我将深入研究理论，并拉出可能或可能不成立的线索。从连环杀手到令人震惊的谋杀案，《线索》深入探讨了所有法医细节和进入世界上最臭名昭著案件的精彩侦探工作。
These clues shine a light on stories that have been waiting, sometimes for decades, to finally be heard. So join us as we open a case and uncover the breakthroughs, the heartbreak, and the relentless pursuit of answers behind these unforgettable investigations. Follow and listen to Clues, an Odyssey podcast and partnership with Crime House, available now on the free Odyssey app
这些线索照亮了那些等待了有时几十年才最终被听到的故事。所以加入我们，当我们打开一个案件并揭开这些令人难忘的调查背后的突破、心碎和对答案的不懈追求。关注并收听《线索》，这是一个与犯罪屋合作的 Odyssey 播客，现在可以在免费的 Odyssey 应用程序上收听
and wherever you get your podcasts. There are very few things that you can be certain of in life. But you can always be sure the sun will rise each morning. You can bet your bottom dollar that you'll always need air to breathe and water to drink. And of course, you can rest assured that with Public Mobile's 5G subscription phone plans, you'll pay the same thing every month. With all of the mysteries that life has to offer, a few certainties can really go a long way. Subscribe today for the peace of minds you've been searching for. Public Mobile. Different is calling.
以及任何你获取播客的地方。生活中你可以确定的事情很少。但你可以始终确定太阳每天早上都会升起。你可以确信你总是需要空气来呼吸，水来喝。当然，你可以放心，使用 Public Mobile 的 5G 订阅电话套餐，你每个月支付的费用都是一样的。随着生活提供的所有谜团，一些确定性真的可以大有帮助。今天订阅，寻找你一直在寻找的内心平静。Public Mobile。与众不同正在呼唤。
Okay, we are back. It starts off with Dwight being so pleasant, trimming his fingernails at work. Why Dwight? Why? Gross. We reveal guess who's sitting next to him. Not Jim. And no longer the temp, it's Ryan. And can we talk about that?
好的，我们回来了。开头是德怀特表现得如此愉快，在工作中修剪指甲。为什么德怀特？为什么？恶心。我们揭示猜猜谁坐在他旁边。不是吉姆。也不再是临时工，是瑞安。我们可以谈谈这个吗？
Uh, Ryan got a whole new look. A bunch of people look a little different. A little better. He like cut his hair short and it's not floppy anymore and it looks like there's some gel. Anyway, this is the new improved Ryan He's no longer the tip and he's got a whole new look. Well, then we move to Pam typing at her desk and she looks Longingly over at Jim's old desk at Ryan and This is when we flash back to casino night. Oh my god, we get an extension
呃，瑞安有了全新的造型。很多人看起来有点不同。好一点。他剪短了头发，不再那么软塌塌的，看起来好像用了发胶。总之，这是全新的改进版瑞安。他不再是临时工，他有了全新的造型。嗯，然后我们转到帕姆在她的桌子上打字，她渴望地看着吉姆的旧桌子，看着瑞安，这就是我们闪回到《赌场之夜》的时候。哦，天哪，我们得到了一个加长版
We see that a whole thing happen after the kiss. yes they both admit to each other that they've wanted to do that for a long time and pam is like i think we're drunk and jim's like i'm not drunk are you drunk and she's like no no i'm not drunk and then jim goes in for another kiss. Yeah. And she's like, I can't. And he's like, you're going to marry him? And you were like, yes.
我们看到吻之后发生了一整件事。是的，他们都向对方承认他们想那样做很久了，帕姆说我觉得我们喝醉了，吉姆说我没喝醉，你喝醉了吗？她说不，不，我没喝醉，然后吉姆又吻了上去。是的。她说，我不能。他说，你要嫁给他？你说，是的。
I know. We had a lot of fan questions about this. Jenna Adams, Matt Grasso, Brett Hedges, Alyssa Dunn, and many others wanted to know, did we film the continuation of the kiss scene at the same time as Casino Night? Or did we have to recreate the moment for Gay Witch Hunt? Guys, we had to recreate it.
我知道。我们有很多关于这个的粉丝问题。珍娜·亚当斯、马特·格拉索、布雷特·赫奇斯、艾丽莎·邓恩和许多其他人想知道，我们是在《赌场之夜》的同时拍摄吻戏的延续吗？还是我们必须为《同性恋猎巫行动》重现那一刻？伙计们，我们必须重现它。
We had to recreate it. And this is like, thank God for Ken Quapus. Thank God we had the same director. So we had to redo everything. Kim Ferry had taken photos of every side of my head and she painstakingly redid my hairdo. Thank God my dress still fit. We added a new camera angle. I don't know if you noticed that.
我们必须重现它。这就像，感谢上帝有肯·夸皮斯。感谢上帝我们有同一位导演。所以我们必须重做一切。金·费里拍了我头部的每一面的照片，她费尽心思重做了我的发型。感谢上帝我的裙子还能穿。我们增加了一个新的摄像机角度。我不知道你是否注意到了。
They set up the spy shot from the kitchen and then they put an extra camera inside the conference room shooting through the blinds so that you could finally now see Pam's face and Pam's reaction. I don't know if this is true, Jenna. And I don't know if it's just because I had this information in my brain that I knew you had to recreate this moment. This is ridiculous,
他们设置了从厨房拍摄的间谍镜头，然后在会议室里放了一个额外的摄像机，透过百叶窗拍摄，这样你现在终于可以看到帕姆的脸和帕姆的反应了。我不知道这是不是真的，珍娜。我不知道这是否只是因为我的大脑里有这个信息，我知道你必须重现这一刻。这太荒谬了，
but I do feel like you're at a different position on Jim's desk. I feel like you're, you're a little further down. I feel like you're not right by the phone, which is where you were, because you had hung up the phone. Right? So this is just a little catch. No, Angela, your catch is good.
但我确实觉得你在吉姆桌子上的位置不同了。我觉得你，你稍微靠下了一点。我觉得你不在电话旁边，那是你之前所在的地方，因为你挂断了电话。对吧？所以这只是一个小发现。不，安吉拉，你的发现很好。
I think in order to get that camera angle through the blinds in the conference room, we had to scoochy scooch just a few inches down the desk. Wow. Wow. I'm impressed that you caught that. I mean, we tried to, we tried our best to fool people, but we had to re-kiss again. Cause you'll notice that, and that was like, by the way, they brought out like a still frame image to me and John
我想为了通过会议室的百叶窗获得那个摄像机角度，我们不得不把桌子往下挪了几英寸。哇。哇。我很佩服你发现了这一点。我的意思是，我们尽力去愚弄人们，但我们不得不再次重吻。因为你会注意到，那就像，顺便说一句，他们拿出一张剧照给我和约翰
of us kissing and they were like, okay, so now Jenna, your arm is here. Your hand is here. John, this is how you had your hand around her. So we had to like painstakingly recreate the pose and everything so that it would look seamless. But if you watch, we kiss and we pull away and start talking immediately. So that was, it was all recreation. How awkward, just think about this.
我们接吻的照片，他们说，好吧，现在珍娜，你的手臂在这里。你的手在这里。约翰，这就是你把手放在她周围的方式。所以我们不得不费尽心思重现姿势和一切，这样它看起来才会天衣无缝。但如果你看，我们接吻然后分开，立即开始说话。所以那是，那全是重现。多尴尬，想想这个。
Here's your job. You go to work one day and someone's like, here's your job today. You need to find a photo of Jenna and John kissing as Jim and Pam. You need to print it out. I need multiple copies. A lot of people are gonna be studying this photo.
这就是你的工作。你有一天去上班，有人说，这是你今天的工作。你需要找到一张珍娜和约翰作为吉姆和帕姆接吻的照片。你需要把它打印出来。我需要多份副本。很多人会研究这张照片。
Then we're gonna take it to Jenna and John. We're gonna recreate the moment. I want it high res. I want it in color. Print me a bunch of photos of them kissing. Okay, thanks. Yeah, that was pretty much it, Ange. That was pretty much it.
然后我们要把它带给珍娜和约翰。我们要重现那一刻。我想要高分辨率的。我想要彩色的。给我打印一堆他们接吻的照片。好的，谢谢。是的，基本上就是这样，安吉。基本上就是这样。
That was someone's job. That's so crazy. All right, well, I love that little behind the scenes moment, Jenna. I love that you acknowledged that you weren't kissing by the phone where you hung up with your mom. I love it. But I want to get into the episode a little bit here.
那是某人的工作。这太疯狂了。好了，好吧，我喜欢那个小小的幕后时刻，珍娜。我喜欢你承认你不是在电话旁边接吻，那是你和你妈妈挂断电话的地方。我喜欢它。但我想要深入探讨一下这一集。
Now Toby is in Michael's office. We're at two minutes, 13 seconds. He's talking to Toby, because apparently Michael was inappropriate again. You know, he basically gives Oscar a hard time for liking Shakespeare in love instead of Die Hard. Yeah. And maybe doesn't
现在托比在迈克尔的办公室里。我们在两分 13 秒。他在和托比说话，因为显然迈克尔又表现得不恰当了。你知道，他基本上因为奥斯卡喜欢《莎翁情史》而不是《虎胆龙威》而让他难堪。是的。而且可能没有
word it very well, you guys. Doesn't word it the best. But when you watch this scene, watch Steve's performance as Michael realizes that Oscar is actually gay. Yes. His transformation of going from like, yeah, yeah, yeah, whatever. Yeah, no, I know. And then it's such a great acting moment in my opinion. Steve once again just blew me away. And here's my other thing I need to point out in this scene, you guys. And I don't know, maybe it's controversial, but you know who I think outed Oscar? Toby!
说得很好，伙计们。虽然不是说得最好。但当你观看这一幕时，请留意迈克尔意识到奥斯卡其实是同性恋时史蒂夫的表演。是的。他从那种“是啊，是啊，是啊，无所谓。是啊，不，我知道”的状态转变过来。在我看来，这是一个非常棒的表演时刻。史蒂夫再一次让我惊叹不已。还有一件事我必须在这一幕中指出，伙计们。我不知道，也许这很有争议，但你知道我认为是谁让奥斯卡出柜的吗？托比！
Toby! Yes! This is gonna come up later Angela because Jan is gonna come into the office and reprimand Michael for outing Oscar to the rest of the office and she goes on this whole speech where she's like it is a big moment in a person's life and they should be able to choose how and when they come out to people. And the whole time I just kept thinking, Toby! Toby outdid Oscar! Oscar told that to Toby in confidence.
托比！没错！安吉拉，这稍后会提到，因为简会来到办公室，斥责迈克尔向办公室其他人公开了奥斯卡的性取向，她发表了一大通演讲，大意是一个人生命中的重要时刻，他们应该能够选择如何以及何时向他人出柜。而整个过程中我一直在想，托比！是托比让奥斯卡出柜的！奥斯卡是私下告诉托比的。
Yes! And Toby told the one person who would not be able to contain that information. Here's two people Toby could have told if he wanted everyone to know. Michael and Kelly. Correct. There you go. There you go. So now, I mean, Michael decides he's got to apologize to Oscar. Of course, it's not in private. He just walks over to the accounting desk pod. You have Kevin and Angela exchanging some glances. And then Michael's like, well, maybe, you know, we could go out to dinner and you could explain to me how it works. And Oscar's like, yeah, that would be wonderful. Yeah, we should do that.
没错！而托比告诉了那个最藏不住话的人。如果托比想让大家都知道，他本可以告诉这两个人：迈克尔和凯利。没错。就是这样。就是这样。所以现在，迈克尔决定他必须向奥斯卡道歉。当然，不是私下道歉。他直接走到会计部门的办公区。你可以看到凯文和安吉拉交换了眼神。然后迈克尔说，嗯，也许，你知道，我们可以出去吃顿晚餐，你可以向我解释一下这是怎么回事。奥斯卡说，是的，那太好了。是的，我们应该那样做。
Oh, Angela, Angela, I have the script for Gay Witch Hunt. Oscar improvised. Did Oscar improvise? That would be wonderful. Steve and Oscar improvised that whole couplet. That is not in the script. I wondered. Yeah. Now listen, I say improvised. Sometimes the writers were on set,
哦，安吉拉，安吉拉，我有《同性恋猎巫》的剧本。奥斯卡是即兴发挥的。奥斯卡即兴发挥了吗？“那太好了。”史蒂夫和奥斯卡即兴发挥了那两句台词。剧本里没有。我还在想呢。是啊。现在听着，我说即兴发挥，有时编剧会在片场，
and they would pitch lines to the actors. But I know that in this particular episode, Steve and Oscar took a lot of liberties. They are both masterful improvisers. And they improvised a lot on these scenes. And I believe that Steve improvised that line about maybe we could go have a beer and you could just tell me how you do that to other dudes. And that Oscar was like that. Yes, Michael, that sounds wonderful. That's wonderful. What a wonderful, I can't wait. It was like the
他们会向演员提议台词。但我知道在这一集中，史蒂夫和奥斯卡做了很多自由发挥。他们都是即兴表演的大师。他们在这些场景中即兴发挥了很多。我相信史蒂夫即兴发挥了那句关于“也许我们可以去喝杯啤酒，你可以告诉我你是怎么对其他男人做那种事的”的台词。而奥斯卡回答说“是的，迈克尔，听起来太棒了”。太棒了。多么美妙，我等不及了。就像是
tone in his voice. But everything about those two together in this episode completely delighted me. I was so tickled. They're so good. They're so good. They're so good. And you know, then we have Kevin and Angela. They know now, right? Here we go. here we go. We're off to the races. Off to the races and now are very, two random pieces of trivia, okay? In my journal, I wrote that I really like this sweater
他说话的语气。但这一集中他们俩在一起的一切都让我感到非常愉悦。我被逗乐了。他们太棒了。他们太棒了。他们太棒了。你知道，然后是凯文和安吉拉。他们现在知道了，对吧？开始了。开始了。我们出发了。出发了，现在有两个随机的琐事，好吗？在我的日记里，我写道我真的很喜欢这件毛衣
that I'm wearing and that I asked the wardrobe department where they got it and they got it at Urban Outfitters. Did you buy one for yourself in your personal life? I didn't, I think I was considering it and then maybe thought it'd be too weird, but to walk around in the sweater my character wears. But yeah, so that sweater was from Urban Outfitters. So look at that, Angela Martin.
我穿着它，我问服装部门他们是在哪里买的，他们是在Urban Outfitters买的。你在现实生活中给自己买了一件吗？我没有，我想我考虑过，然后可能觉得穿着我角色穿的毛衣到处走会太奇怪了。但是的，那件毛衣来自Urban Outfitters。所以看看那个，安吉拉·马丁。
That's kind of a hip store, but maybe we had a bigger budget. Yeah. So wardrobe stopped going to like the NBC warehouse and getting the older clothes and went to Urban Outfitters for Angela Martin and then the other thing is at three minutes 58 seconds that Whatever photocopy picture of the dog the rescue dog is no longer on my partition. Oh yeah that was always on your partition. It's not there Oh removed for season three removed for season three. Removed for season three.
那是一家挺时髦的店，但也许我们有更多的预算。是的。所以服装部门不再去NBC仓库拿旧衣服，而是为安吉拉·马丁去了Urban Outfitters。还有一件事，在3分58秒时，那张无论是什么的救援犬复印照片不再贴在我的隔板上了。哦，是的，那一直贴在你的隔板上。它不在那儿了。哦，第三季移除了，第三季移除了。第三季移除了。
It's gone. If you're a regular listener to this podcast, you know we've been tracking this picture of a dog on Angela's partition. Yeah, it's gone. It's gone. Oh, everyone's so, everyone's so relieved by that. Everyone is so thrilled by that information. It's going to be the big takeaway from today's episode. Yeah, exactly. That's what everyone's going to talk about. And then I just want to point out big takeaway from today's episode. Yeah, exactly. That's what everyone's going to talk about. And then I just want to point out, I thought Oscar's talking head, where at first he's denying being gay, and then he just is like, you know what?
它不见了。如果你是这个播客的常客，你就知道我们一直在追踪安吉拉隔板上的那张狗的照片。是的，它不见了。它不见了。哦，每个人都，每个人都对此感到如释重负。每个人都对这个信息感到非常激动。这将是今天这一集最大的收获。是的，完全正确。这就是每个人都会谈论的事情。然后我只想指出，今天这一集最大的收获。是的，完全正确。这就是每个人都会谈论的事情。然后我只想指出，我觉得奥斯卡的访谈片段，起初他否认自己是同性恋，然后他只是说，你知道吗？
Yeah, I am. OK. I thought he did such a great job. I mean, he's fantastic in this whole episode, but it's just a really small, quick talking head. But I thought he just really found some layers to it and I thought it was perfect. Well, you know, there's another talking head that Oscar has in the script that I thought was really, really interesting.
是的，我是。好吧。我觉得他做得太棒了。我的意思是，他在整集中都很出色，但这只是一个非常简短、快速的访谈片段。但我认为他真的挖掘出了一些层次，我觉得这很完美。嗯，你知道，奥斯卡在剧本里还有另一个访谈片段，我觉得非常、非常有趣。
That didn't get in. It didn't get in. He says, when I applied for my job at Dunder Mifflin, I told Michael in my interview that I was gay. Oh, I saw this! I saw this in the deleted scenes! And he couldn't stop laughing. Yes! He just kept laughing and laughing and laughing and then he hired me and said, I'm hilarious and that's why I've never come out at the office.
没能放进去。没放进去。他说，当我申请邓德·米夫林的职位时，我在面试中告诉迈克尔我是同性恋。哦，我看到了！我在删减片段里看到了！他笑得停不下来。是的！他一直笑个不停，然后他雇用了我，说我很滑稽，这就是为什么我从未在办公室出柜。
I just decided to keep it to myself after that. Yes, that's right. If you guys have the DVD set that is in the deleted scenes, it's really funny. It was very funny when I was reading through the script and I came across that. Yes, that's right. If you guys have the DVD set that is in the deleted scenes, it's really funny It was very funny when I was reading through the script and I came across that. Oh good. So they actually filmed it. That's cool Yeah, it's in the deleted scenes Well guys now we're gonna go over to Stanford Jim is on the phone in his new fancy office He is assuring a customer that while he cannot say that Dunder Mifflin paper is less flammable He will promise that is definitely not less flammable, he will promise
在那之后，我决定把它藏在心里。是的，没错。如果你们有DVD套装，那就在删减片段里，真的很有趣。当我读剧本读到那里时，觉得非常有趣。是的，没错。如果你们有DVD套装，那就在删减片段里，真的很有趣。当我读剧本读到那里时，觉得非常有趣。哦，太好了。所以他们真的拍了。那很酷。是的，它在删减片段里。好吧，伙计们，现在我们要去斯坦福分部了。吉姆正在他那间豪华的新办公室里打电话。他向一位客户保证，虽然他不能说邓德·米夫林的纸张不易燃，但他会承诺它绝对不会比其他纸张更易燃。那是对纸张的推销。我们有一个来自凯瑟琳·兰格里奇的粉丝提问/粉丝发现，在4分53秒。安吉拉，你注意到约翰的电脑上有一张便利贴，上面只写着“微笑”这个词吗？没有。上面写着“微笑”，她写信来说，那是吉姆写给吉姆的便条，还是同事写给吉姆的便条？不管怎样，吉姆现在是个忧郁的家伙。我觉得那一定是吉姆写给吉姆的，因为我的意思是，我不知道他有没有一个会写“微笑”并贴在他桌子上的朋友。我不知道。我同意。
that is definitely not more flammable than other paper. That's a sales pitch for the paper. And we had a fan question slash fan catch from Katherine Langridge at four minutes 53 seconds. Angela, did you notice that there is a post-it note on John's computer that just says the word smile? No. It says smile and she wrote in to say, is that a note from Jim to Jim or a note from a coworker to Jim? Either way, Jim is a sad dude right now. It would have to be, I feel like it's Jim to Jim because I mean, I don't know that he has a pal that's going to write smile and stick it on his desk. I don't know. I agree.
我认为这表明吉姆真的很孤独。是的。所以安迪要告诉吉姆离远处那个金发女郎远点。我感觉那可能是安迪喜欢的某个人。他只是不想让吉姆去搭讪她。哦，那是个好主意，是的。就是这样，因为他说，是的，她很疯狂。离远点。去开阔水域吧。这让我笑喷了。这有点回到你刚才说的事情，就是安迪已经有了航海参考。航海参考。是的。是的。他，我敢肯定安迪有着那种东海岸特权生活，他在航海。哦，是的，我们了解到他，他要，他航海，他穿着他所有那些小小的，比如
I think it's an indication that Jim's real lonely. Yeah. So then Andy is going to tell Jim to sort of stay away from this blonde that they can see off in the distance. I sort of felt like probably that was someone Andy liked. He just didn't want Jim to like hit on her. Oh, that's a good, yeah. That's what, because he was like, yeah, she's crazy. Steer clear. Head for open waters. And it cracked me up. And it kind of goes back to the thing you were saying is that already with Andy, we have the nautical references. nautical references. Yes. Yes. He I'm sure that Andy with that whole East Coast privileged life, he's a he's sailing. Oh, yeah, we learned that he's he's gonna he sails he wears all his little like
他为船上派对准备的服装。没错。他那双小小的码头鞋。然后人们穿什么？我不知道。是的，划船的人。我们划船的人。不是我穿的。嗯，然后我们发现为什么吉姆被称为“大金枪鱼”。是的。现在我得问你这个。我得问你这个，因为安迪不认识吉姆。
outfits that he's ready for like the boat party. That's right. His little dockers shoes. And then what people wear? I don't know. Yeah, boating people. We're gonna boating people right in. Not when I wear. Um, and then we find out why Jim is called Big Tuna. Yes. Now I have to ask you about this. I have to ask you about this because Andy doesn't know Jim.
他真的对他一无所知，但他已经给他起了个绰号。我知道我生命中有个人就是这样，会直接给别人起绰号。这对我来说总是很奇怪。吉姆在上班第一天吃了一个金枪鱼三明治，现在被安迪称为“大金枪鱼”。我想有人写信进来，我很喜欢这个评论。很抱歉我忘了写下他们的名字，但他们提到他们觉得吉姆在斯坦福第一天吃金枪鱼三明治而不是
He really doesn't know anything about him, but he's already given him a nickname. I know I have someone in my life that is like this that will give people nicknames right out of the gate. It's always really weird to me. And Jim on his first day of work, ate a tuna sandwich and now is referred to as Big Tuna by Andy. I think somebody wrote in and I liked this comment. I'm sorry I forgot to write down their name, but they mentioned they felt like that the piece of information that Jim ate a tuna sandwich instead of
他通常吃的火腿奶酪三明治，是吉姆试图拓展自己的一种方式，也许这是一个微妙的暗示。嗯。我想过这个问题。我想过这个问题。但你知道他本可以吃他的火腿三明治，我想安迪可能会叫他“火腿骨”之类的。那可能是我高中时的绰号。只是想和你分享一下。什么？你高中时的绰号是“火腿骨”？嗯，有一年。什么？你高中时的绰号是“火腿骨”？嗯，有一年。
his usual ham and cheese sandwich on his first day at Stanford, was another way that Jim is trying to branch out maybe that it was a subtle indication of that. Mm-hmm. I thought about that. I thought about that. But you know he could have had his ham sandwich and I guess Andy could have called him ham bone or something. That might have been my nickname in high school. Just gonna share that with you. What? Your nickname in high school was ham bone? Well for one year. What? Your nickname in high school was Hambone? Well, for one year.
那是什么意思？那是什么意思？所以有个叫马克的人，他在一场橄榄球赛后开了个派对，我们都去了他家，他父母不在城里，我当时就像。我不知道。我要死了。我只是在想火腿或骨头
What does that mean? What does that mean? So there was a guy named Mark and he had a party after like a football game and we all went over to his house and his parents were out of town and I was like. I don't know. I'm dying. I'm just trying to figure out how ham or bone
是怎么扯到故事里来的。所以不管怎样，马克在橄榄球赛后开了这个派对。我们都在那儿。他父母不在城里。我敢肯定他们不会想让我们在那儿。我当时超级饿。我穿着我的啦啦队服。
is gonna come into the story. So anyway, Mark is having this party after a football game. We're all over there. His parents are out of town. I'm sure they wouldn't want us there. And I was super hungry. And I'm in like my cheerleading outfit.
我超级饿。我走进厨房，在黑暗中，我不开任何灯，我打开冰箱门。其他人都在露台上喝啤酒什么的，我打开冰箱门，里面有一大块火腿。不。里面有一大块火腿。
I'm super hungry. And I go into the kitchen and within the dark, I don't turn on any lights and I open the fridge door. Everyone else is out on like the patio drinking beer or whatever and I open the fridge door and there's a huge ham. No. There's a huge ham in there.
我就开始吃火腿，站在冰箱门前，只有冰箱的光照着我，马克走了进来，打开灯，说：“金西，你在干什么？”我说：“我只是在吃点火腿。”就是这样。他们就像“火腿骨，火腿骨，火腿骨”，然后每个人都开始叫我“火腿骨”。我无语了。好吧，我只是说安迪本可以叫吉姆“火腿骨”。但这和
And I just started eating ham standing in the fridge door with just the light of the fridge hitting me and Mark walked in and Flipped on the light and was like Kinsey. What are you doing? I was like, I'm just eating some ham and that was it They were like ham bone ham bone ham bone and then everyone start calling me ham bone. This is I'm speechless Well, all I'm saying is Andy could have called Jim ham bone But it doesn't quite work with
整个航海的事情不太搭。所以我喜欢这个人说，哦，吉姆正在开始新的生活。他正在吃金枪鱼三明治。他在豪华的斯坦福工作。但也可能只是因为考虑到安迪的角色，“大金枪鱼”更有趣。我这里有几个关于吉姆访谈片段的评论。不是要啰嗦，但在他的一个访谈片段中，我们有一个来自阿莎·哈恩哈特的粉丝发现，她说，在4分46秒，吉姆正在解释他为什么要转到斯坦福，他说他被升职了。但是
the whole nautical thing. So I like that this person is like, oh, Jim is starting new. He's having tuna fish sandwiches. He's working in fancy Stanford. But it also might just be that big tuna is funnier given Andy's character. I've got a couple of comments about Jim's talking heads here. Not to belabor, but in his one talking head we had a fan catch from Asha Harnhart who said, at 4 minutes 46 seconds, Jim is explaining why he transferred to Stanford and he says that he's been promoted. But
据我所知，他的工作似乎并没有什么改变。只是地点变了。所以他真的升职了吗？是的，在剧本里，那个访谈片段是延长的。他们为这一集剪掉了。他解释说他是斯坦福的助理区域经理。是的。他基本上就是斯坦福的德怀特。DVD套装里有一个很棒的删减片段。这是我这一集中最喜欢的。凯伦是吉姆。凯伦捉弄吉姆。她把他的外拨号码设置成打到香港。所以每次他拨出电话，他都会打到香港，他说：“这到底是怎么回事？”然后你看到凯伦那种坏笑，他被捉弄了，他说：“我是助理区域经理。”她说：“是啊，好吧。”
from what I can tell, it doesn't seem like his job has changed anymore. It's just the location. So was he really promoted? Yes, in the script, that talking head is extended. They cut it out for the episode. He explains that he is the assistant regional manager of Stanford. Yes. He is basically Dwight of Stanford. And there is a great deleted scene on the DVD box set. It's my favorite from this whole episode. Karen is Jim. Karen pranks Jim. She sets his dial-out number to go to Hong Kong. So every time he dials out, he calls Hong Kong and he's like, what the heck? And then you see sort of like Karen's smirk and he's being pranked and he says, I'm the assistant regional manager and she's like, yeah, okay.
所以在我心里，我想，哦天哪，吉姆是德怀特，凯伦是这个办公室里的吉姆。安吉拉，我觉得这一集有无数的删减片段。有很多，它有点充实了斯坦福的世界。所以我建议观看它们，但是的，伙计们，凯伦就是吉姆。
So to me in my mind, I was like, oh my God, Jim is Dwight, Karen is Jim in this office. Angela, I think there's like a gazillion deleted scenes from this episode. There are a bunch and it sort of like flushes out the world of Stanford. And so I would recommend watching them, but yeah, you guys, Karen is Jim.
凯伦看着吉姆的方式就像吉姆过去看着德怀特的方式，并捉弄他。他说：“但我有这个头衔。”她说：“我。”好吧。是的，后来在会议室里，她会说他有点像个马屁精。是的。是的。他确实有点在拍老板的马屁，就像德怀特拍迈克尔的马屁一样。是的。我还有另一个关于吉姆访谈片段的珍娜发现。我拒绝离开这个访谈片段。让我们继续谈论它。
Karen looks at Jim the way Jim used to look at Dwight and pranks him. And he's like, but I have this title. And she's like, me. Okay. Yeah. And then later in the conference room, she's going to say he's kind of a kiss ass. Yes. Yes. And he is kind of kissing up to his boss, the way Dwight kisses up to Michael. Yeah. I have another Jenna catch about the Jim talking head. I refuse to leave this talking head. Let's keep talking about it.
我注意到我们之前谈过在斯克兰顿分部，吉姆的访谈片段总是对着外窗，而其他人的访谈片段都对着办公室内部。你可以看到斯坦利和克里德在背景里工作。而这背后的意图，对于任何没听过这个播客上一集的人来说，意图是吉姆有一个未来
I noticed we talked before about how in the Scranton branch, Jim's talking heads were always against an exterior window, whereas everybody else's talking heads faced into the office. And you could see Stanley and Creed working in the background. And that the intention behind this was just for anyone who didn't hear the previous episode of this podcast, that the intention was that Jim had a future
在斯克兰顿之外。所以他的访谈片段对着一扇朝向外面世界的窗户，对吧？是的。在斯坦福，他的访谈片段对着办公室内部。得了吧！他们对着一扇内部窗户。不。
outside of Scranton. And so his talking heads were against a window that faced out into the world, right? Yep. In Stanford, his talking heads face into the office. Come on! They face an interior window. No.
不是外窗。大家，他在斯坦福没有未来。哦，姑娘。那真是好东西，女士。既然我们在谈论访谈片段，让我们谈谈安迪的。他说他去了康奈尔。他四年毕业。
Not an exterior one. He does not have a future in Stanford, everyone. Oh, girl. That is some good stuff, lady. Since we're talking about talking heads, let's talk about Andes for a second. He says he went to Cornell. He graduated in four years.
他从不学习。他一直喝得醉醺醺的，他参加了一个叫“麻烦来了”的阿卡贝拉组合。嗯，我有一个有趣的事实，安吉拉。是关于他的阿卡贝拉组合吗？是的。康奈尔没有一个叫“麻烦来了”的阿卡贝拉组合。没有吗？不，它不存在。那是编出来的。
He never studied. He was drunk the whole time and he was in an acapella group called Here Comes Trouble. Well I have a fun fact, Angela. Is it about his acapella group? Yeah. Cornell does not have an acapella group called Here Comes Treble. They don't? No, it does not exist. That is made up.
然而……哦天哪。他们确实有一个全女性的阿卡贝拉组合叫“只有麻烦”。“只有麻烦”？得了吧！女士，你知道我必须调查一下。“只有麻烦”成立于1976年。你必须试镜才能加入这个组合，他们每周有三次两小时的排练
However... Oh my god. They do have an all-female acapella group called Nothing But Treble. Nothing But Treble? Come on! And lady, you know I had to investigate. Nothing But Treble was founded in 1976. You have to audition to be in the group and they have three two hour rehearsals per week
在周二、周四和周日。你去了他们的网站吗？你查了他们的排练时间表？女士，我不仅在他们的网站上花了大约45分钟，我还联系了他们！又名什么？是的，他们给我发了一段他们唱布兰妮·斯皮尔斯的《Hit Me Baby One More Time》的片段。萨姆，放出来。真的太棒了。这真是太棒了。
on Tuesdays, Thursdays and Sundays. What did you go to their website? You looked up their rehearsal schedule? Lady, not only did I spend about 45 minutes on their website, I reached out to them! Aka what? Yeah, and they sent me a clip of themselves singing Britney Spears' Hit Me Baby one more time. Sam, roll it. It's seriously so good. It is aka-awesome.
这真是太棒了。伙计们，这群厉害的女性可以在Instagram上找到，账号是nbt-cornell，或者你可以在Spotify上下载她们的音乐，搜索“Nothing But Treble”。那太棒了。我可能已经那样做了。我可能已经那样做了。你可能已经做了。我想你做了。
It's aka-awesome. Guys, this badass group of women can be found on Instagram at nbt-cornell or you can download their music at nothing but treble on Spotify. That's awesome. I might have done that. I might have done that. You might have done it. I think you did.
你知道排练时间表是什么时候。我可能有她们的整张专辑。你要做什么？这周加入她们的Zoom排练时间表吗？你知道，我可能真的会。我可能真的会。好吧。嗯，当我们谈论访谈片段时，
You know when the rehearsal schedule is. I might have their whole album. What are you going to do? Join their Zoom rehearsal schedule this week? You know, I just might. I just might. Okay. Well, while we're talking talking heads,
我想谈谈凯伦的访谈片段。凯伦的访谈片段。伙计们，去6分17秒，看看对吉姆看镜头的表情的精彩模仿。拉什达·琼斯演得太棒了。她看向镜头说：“他总是这样这样”，然后她做了他的表情，她说：“那是怎么回事？”就像那是什么？太棒了。所以我给拉什达发了短信，我说：“拉什达，我现在正在看你。做你对吉姆看镜头的模仿，这让我笑喷了。你演得太棒了。”她说：“哦天哪，安吉拉，那太好了。”她说她当时紧张得要命。她告诉我，她确信自己会被解雇。她还说，最初这个角色被写得更暴躁、刻薄、刻薄。那是她的原话。她说，她说，这就是为什么我的刘海有点
I want to talk about Karen's talking head. Karen's talking head. You guys go to six minutes, 17 seconds for a fantastic impression of Jim's look to camera. Rashida Jones crushes it. She looks to camera and goes, and he's always doing this this and she does his face and she goes what's that about? Like what is that? It's so good. So I texted Rashida and I was like Rashida I am watching you right now. Do your impression of Jim's look to camera and it is cracking me up. You crushed it and she was like oh my gosh, Angel that's so nice. She said I was so damn nervous. She told me she was convinced that she was going to get fired. She also said originally the character was written to be more ornery, sour, and mean. Those were her exact words. And she said, she said, that's why my bangs are sort
像别在额头上，我几乎没化什么妆。他们只是认为凯伦可能会稍微粗鲁一点，有点刻薄。然后她说格雷格决定软化她。所以下一集，她稍微温柔了一点。她没那么刻薄了。这太有趣了。你知道，安吉拉，夏天的时候我被叫去和一群不同的凯伦进行试镜，拉什达就是其中之一。所以他们把范围缩小到三个凯伦，我必须进去，我必须
of like pinned to my forehead and I'm not wearing hardly any makeup. They just thought that Karen was gonna be maybe a little bit more gruff and kind of a meanie. And then she said that Greg decided to soften her. And so in the next episode, she's a little softer. She's not quite so sour. That is so interesting. You know, Angela, I was brought in over the summer to screen test with a bunch of different Karens and Rashida was one of them. So they had whittled it down to three Karens and I had to come in and I had to
作为帕姆和她们读剧本。他们写了这一幕，但从未拍摄。这是一个你从未见过的凯伦和帕姆的场景，但他们只是为了试镜的目的写了它，我必须进去读。在这一切结束时，他们说：“你最喜欢谁？”我说：“我最喜欢拉什达·琼斯。”她只是让我感觉到了，就像我说的关于约翰的那件事。当我见到约翰时，有一种瞬间的化学反应，因为他让扮演帕姆变得最容易。这就是我描述给
read scenes with them as Pam. They wrote this scene that was never shot. It was a Karen Pam scene that you never see, but they just wrote it for the purposes of the audition and I had to come in and read. And at the end of it all, they said, who did you like best? And I said, my favorite was Rashida Jones. She just made me feel it was that same thing that I've said about John. When I met John, there was this instant chemistry because he made it the easiest to be Pam. And that's how I described it to
他们听的方式。我说，我和她演对手戏时，甚至觉得不需要努力。我毫不费力地感受到了帕姆和凯伦之间的化学反应。我知道帕姆和凯伦是谁，她们会成为什么样的人。我也认为从试镜的那一刻起，安吉拉，我就立刻把她看作是我钦佩的一个闪亮的东西。
them. I said, I just didn't even feel like I had to work hard in my scenes with her. I effortlessly felt this chemistry between Pam and Karen. I knew who Pam and Karen were and who they were gonna be. I also think from that first moment in that audition, Angela, I immediately saw her as a little bit of like this shiny object that I admired.
她是一个如此酷的女性，以至于我想，哦，这对帕姆和凯伦来说也是一个很好的动态。因为我认为帕姆确实把凯伦看作是一个她渴望成为的女性。凯伦有一种内在的自信。她有她不害怕的野心。所以我感受到了这一切，即使从我们第一次见面开始。我当时太兴奋了，因为我不认为他们一定会关心
She was such a cool woman that I was like, oh, that's a good dynamic for Pam and Karen too. Because I think Pam does look at Karen as a woman she would aspire to be. Karen has an inner confidence. She has ambition that she's not afraid of. And so I felt all of that at play, even from our very first time meeting. And I was just so excited because I didn't think they would necessarily care
我认为谁是我最有共鸣的人，但当她被选中时，我感到非常兴奋。是的。所以对我来说很有趣的是，她以为自己会被解雇，因为我记得所有关于她试镜的谈话，每个人都说：“她就是。她就是凯伦。她就是那个人。”
who I thought was the person I responded the most to, but it made me so excited when she was cast. Yeah. So it's funny to me that she thought she was going to get fired because I remember all the conversations about her audition and how everyone was like, she is it. She is Karen. She is the one.
嗯，她给我发短信说，在拍摄第一天之前，她可能整个星期都没睡着。她说她有一种巨大的恐慌，观众会讨厌她，因为凯伦介入了帕姆和吉姆之间。她说：“哦天哪，他们会讨厌她，因为凯伦介入了帕姆和吉姆之间，她说：‘哦天哪，他们所有人都会讨厌我。’”嗯，你知道，拉什达和我过去常谈论这个，最终有一整件事是“帕姆队”对“凯伦队”。我告诉她：“我不知道，我必须对你诚实。如果我在看这个，我可能实际上会是‘凯伦队’的。我可能。”是的。即使
Well, she texted me that she did not sleep probably the whole week before her first day of filming. And she said she had just like major panic that the viewers were going to hate her because Karen gets in the middle between Pam and Jim. And she was like, Oh my God, they're were going to hate her because Karen gets in the middle between Pam and Jim and she was like, Oh my God, they're all going to hate me. Well, you know, Rashida and I used to talk about that and eventually there's like a whole thing where it was team Pam, team Karen. And I told her, I don't know, I have to be honest with you. If I was watching this, I might actually be team Karen. I might. Yeah. Even
我是帕姆。所以我告诉她，别担心。会有很多人知道你只是一个很棒的女士。所以，是的，我告诉拉什达，我觉得她做得很好。我的意思是，凯伦是一个非常艰难的角色，因为她踏入了神圣的土地。那就是吉姆和帕姆。但我认为她是一个出色的陪衬。拉什达说她很乐意来参加节目。她说也许《本尼·汉纳圣诞节》会很有趣。
though I am Pam. So I told her, don't worry about it. There's going to be plenty of people who know you're just a great lady. So, yeah, I told Rashida, I thought she did a great job. I mean, Karen is a really tough role because she treads on the sacred ground. That is Jim and Pam. But I thought she was a fantastic foil. And Rashida said that she would love to come on the show. She said maybe Benny Hanna Christmas would be fun.
是的。所以我们也要把拉什达请到这里来。拉什达，非常感谢。我爱她。我知道。好吧。我们应该回到斯克兰顿分部，谈谈迈克尔和德怀特在迈克尔办公室里监视每个人的事吗？哦，你是说我标题为“变得自大”的那部分吗？哦，解释一下。在6分56秒，你知道，迈克尔正在建议他认为办公室里谁可能是同性恋。他说也许是安吉拉。德怀特非常自鸣得意地看向镜头
Yes. So we're going to get Rashida on here too. And Rashida, thank you so much. I love her. I know. All right. Should we go back to the Scranton branch and talk about Michael and Dwight spying on everyone from inside of Michael's office? Oh, do you mean what I titled getting cocky? Oh, explain. At six minutes, 56 seconds, you know, Michael is suggesting who he thinks might be gay in the office. He says maybe Angela. And Dwight looks very smugly to camera
说：“我真的不这么认为。”就像安吉拉不是同性恋，他知道原因。但他给了镜头一个完全直接的眼神，非常自鸣得意和自大。我当时想：“德怀特，你在干什么？”是的。德怀特，我们在秘密恋爱。你不能给摄影师一个小小的眨眼，
and says, I really don't think so. And like that Angela isn't gay and he knows why. But he gives a total look straight to camera, really smug and cocky. I'm like, Dwight, what are you doing? Yeah. Dwight, we are in a secret relationship. You don't get to give a little wink,
眨眼。他在干什么？是的。他变得自大了。他变得自大了。我们知道摄像人员知道，因为他们在那个游戏屋里发现了你们，但你们不知道他们知道。
wink to the cameraman. What is he doing? Yeah. He's getting cocky. He's getting cocky. We know that the camera people know because they found you in that playhouse, but you guys don't know that they know.
德怀特不知道。所以他为什么要给镜头那个自鸣得意的眨眼表情？他无法控制自己。他无法控制自己。他无法控制自己。他很高兴能和你谈恋爱，安吉拉。我知道，我知道。嗯，他们还谈论“同性恋雷达”，
Dwight doesn't know. So why is he giving the little smug wink look to camera? He couldn't help himself. He couldn't help himself. He couldn't help himself. He's delighted to be in this relationship with you, Angela. I know, I know. Well, they also talk about gaydar,
吉姆告诉德怀特，你可以买一个设备，告诉你某人是否是同性恋。他们决定他们需要得到它。所以他们给吉姆打电话。这是他们做的一件事，这样他们就可以保持这种小小的恶作剧关系，并让吉姆成为我们世界的一部分，这样你就能看到。你会看到这一点在第三季中继续发展。
that Jim told Dwight that you can buy a device that tells you whether or not someone is gay. They decide they need to get it. So they call Jim. And this was a thing that they did so that they could keep up this little pranky relationship and keep Jim part of our world so that you could see. And you'll see this going forward in season three.
会有一些方式，特别是在下一集中，会有一个大会，吉姆会去参加这个大会，并与迈克尔重聚。所以不管怎样，他们确实，他们确实想找到即使在这一集中，吉姆与斯克兰顿和迈克尔与德怀特重新联系的方式。所以他们用“同性恋雷达”做到了。他们用“同性恋雷达”做到了，他们还让布朗先生进来谈论，你知道，某种多样性培训，对吧？这是因为斯克兰顿分部又在闹事了。所以有很多时刻你可以看到吉姆在想斯克兰顿，吉姆在想帕姆，吉姆甚至在想念德怀特
There are going to be ways, especially even in the next episode, there's going to be a convention and Jim is going to go on this convention and be reunited with Michael. And so anyway, they did, they did want to find even in this episode ways that Jim was connected back to Scranton and back to Michael and Dwight. So they did it with Gator. They did it with Gator and they also did it with Mr. Brown having to come in and talk about, you know, sort of like a type of diversity training, right? And it's because the Scranton branch is acting up again. So there's a lot of moments where you get to see Jim thinking about Scranton, Jim thinking about Pam, Jim even missing Dwight
和迈克尔。这是其中一个时刻。我写道，在7分29秒。我认为这是吉姆在这一集中第一次看起来真正快乐，因为他可以和德怀特和迈克尔交谈，并再次嘲笑他们是多么白痴。所以现在我们知道帕姆说她要嫁给罗伊。我们知道吉姆已经搬到了斯坦福，但现在我们要更多地了解帕姆的关系。帕姆在她的桌子旁。罗伊带着两盘食物进来了。他问她想要鸡肉还是鱼。他们进行了一些尴尬的闲聊，然后镜头推向帕姆的左手。没有戒指。整个过程中她都没有戴戒指。甚至没注意到，对吧？是的，所以当那发生时
and Michael. And this is one of those moments. And I wrote that it's seven minutes, 29 seconds. I think it's the first time Jim truly looks happy in this whole episode because he gets to talk to Dwight and Michael and like sort of laugh at what idiots they are once again. So now we know that Pam said she was going to marry Roy. We know that Jim has moved to Stanford, but now we're going to learn more about Pam's relationship. Pam is at her desk. Roy enters with two plates of food. He asks her if she wants chicken or fish. They have a little awkward small talk and then the camera pushes in to Pam's left hand. No ring. This whole time she didn't have a ring on. didn't even notice right yeah, so when that happened
我真的，即使我知道，因为你和我了解这部剧，我当时想：“哦，没有戒指，哦天哪，戒指，没有戒指。”还有真的，嗯，晒黑的罗伊，非常晒黑，身材很好，罗伊。罗伊看起来棒极了。他就像一个真正的男人，当他走路时，他是一杯高大的凉水。帕姆没嫁的那个男人现在突然超级性感。他晒黑了，身材也很好。还有胡子，我为那胡子而活。
I really did even though I knew it because you and I know the show I was like oh no ring oh my god ring no ring and also really um Tan Roy very tan and in shape Roy Roy's looking Amazing he's like on realman is a tall drink of water when he walks. The man that Pam didn't marry is now suddenly super hot. He's tan and in really good shape. And the beard, I'm living for that beard.
一切都很奏效。大卫，一切都很奏效。嗯，帕姆解释说她没有完成婚礼。她在婚礼前几周就退缩了，对吧？她只是知道她必须结束这段关系。她解释说他们仍然必须支付所有的食物费用，所以他们冷冻了它。现在我想她必须在接下来的五周里每天吃鸡肉或鱼。
It's all working. David, it was all working. Well, Pam explains that she did not go through with the wedding. She got cold feet in just like the weeks before, right? And she just knew she had to get out of the relationship. She explains that they still had to pay for all the food, so they froze it. And now I guess she has to eat chicken or fish every day for the next five weeks.
我觉得那是一个非常有趣的细节。非常有趣。而且，你知道，然后罗伊有一个访谈片段，他伤了我的心。在接下来的五周里每天。我觉得那是一个非常有趣的细节。非常有趣。而且，你知道，然后罗伊有一个访谈片段，他伤了我的心。他变得情绪化了。他说他必须把她追回来，你知道，他不会再把她视为理所当然。
I thought that was really funny detail. It's very funny. And, you know, then Roy has a talking head and he broke my heart. every day for the next five weeks. I thought that was really funny detail. It's very funny. And you know, then Roy has a talking head and he broke my heart. He gets emotional. He says he's got to get her back, you know, and he's not going to take her for granted.
我当时想：“哦天哪，超级性感、晒黑、身材好的罗伊现在变得情绪化了。这到底是怎么回事？”我知道他解释说他因为酒驾被捕了。我记得那张酒驾照片，因为我记得——我也是！他就像决定选哪一张。
And I was like, oh my gosh, super hot tan in-shape Roy is now getting emotional. What the heck is happening? I know he explains that he got arrested for a DUI. And they- I remember that DUI photo because I remember- Me too! Him like deciding which one to pick.
我记得那一张让我们笑了，明迪笑得前仰后合。我记得同样的事情。我记得同样的事情。我们有一个来自蕾哈娜·谢里夫的粉丝提问，她说：“他们是怎么制作罗伊的入狱照的？”嗯，听着，事情是这样的。大卫夏天拍了一部电影，
And I remember that one made us laugh and Mindy was like cackling. I remember the same thing. I remember the same thing. We had a fan question from Rihanna Sheriff who said, how did they make the mugshot of Roy? Well, listen, here's the thing. David shot a movie over the summer,
他为了那部电影练出了那种超级棒的身材。他回来拍《办公室》第三季，正如我们讨论过的，他看起来棒极了。格雷格说：“哦，不。我们把你写成因为和帕姆解除婚约而崩溃了。”所以他们不得不稍微重写一下。
and he got into that super amazing shape for that movie. And he came back for season three of The Office, and he, as we have discussed, looked amazing. And Greg was like, oh, no. We had written you as having sort of fallen apart as a result of your broken engagement to Pam. So they had to kind of rewrite it a little bit.
他们想保留关于他被捕的那整段戏。所以他们拍了一张他的照片，然后用Photoshop，他们让他的脸肿了起来。他们吹大了他的脖子。太奇怪了。太奇怪了。太疯狂了，他们带了大约六个不同的选项让我们投票选出我们喜欢的。我完全记得那个，安吉拉。是的，我们笑喷了。哦天哪，太棒了。罗伊很性感。好吧，他正在为帕姆扭转局面，但有人对他们有怨言
They wanted to keep in that whole bit about how he had been arrested. So they took a picture of him and then with Photoshop, they like swelled up his face. They blew out his neck. It was so weird. It was so weird. it was so crazy and they brought around like six different options for all of us to vote on which one we liked. I totally remember that too Angela. yeah we were cracking up. oh my god it was amazing. Roy is hot. okay he's trying to turn a corner here for Pam but there is someone who has a gripe
那就是斯坦利。是的。因为斯坦利给他们的婚礼买了一个烤面包机。然后他们取消了婚礼，他试图退掉烤面包机，但商店不接受退货。你知道我在想什么吗？什么？
with them and it is Stanley. Yeah. Because Stanley bought them a toaster for their wedding. Then they call off their wedding and he tried to return the toaster and the store won't take it back. And you know what I think? What?
我想斯坦利，因为他很吝啬，我们已经确定他有点吝啬，对吧？是的。我想斯坦利给他们买了一个停产的烤面包机，就像那种打折的、清仓的烤面包机。他给他们买了那个烂烤面包机，他退不掉。嗯，那他活该被困在
I think Stanley, because he's cheap, we sort of have established that he's kind of cheap, right? Yeah. I think that Stanley bought them a discontinued toaster, like the toaster that was on sale, like clearance. He bought them the crap toaster in his bum that he couldn't return it. Well, then he deserves to be stuck
两个烤面包机里，不是吗？这就是你得到的。哦，嘿，我们没有这个的结尾，但我想要在9分34秒加一个结尾，大概是这样的，“一个完整的曼迪！”我们需要一个完整的明迪结尾。实际上，我们需要立即着手处理。因为在9分34秒，我们看到了一些真正的长接发。
with two toasters, doesn't he? That's what you get. Oh, hey, we don't have a sting for this, but I would like to put in a sting at nine minutes, 34 seconds that goes something like, a full Mandy! We need a full Mindy sting. We need to get on that immediately, actually. Because at 9 minutes 34 seconds, we see some real long extensions.
哦，是的！还有一件亮绿色的衬衫和一条花裙子。它是完整的。完整的曼迪！没有回头路了。没有回头路了。没有回头路了。此外，她像跳着走到奥斯卡的桌子旁，她只是想告诉他，他是同性恋这件事有多酷
Oh yeah! And a bright green blouse and a floral skirt. It is full. Full Mandy! There's no going back. There's no going back. There's no going back. Also, she like skips up to Oscar's desk and she just wants to tell him how cool it is that he's gay
以及她是如何完全低估了他。然后奥斯卡有了那个让我发痒的精彩访谈片段，他说，是的，他非常、非常酷，因为他是斯克兰顿一家倒闭的纸张供应公司的会计，就像伊恩·麦凯伦爵士一样。是的。
and how she has totally underestimated him. And then Oscar has that amazing talking to head that tickles me where he says, he yes, he's very, very cool because he's an accountant at a failing paper supply company in Scranton, much like Sir Ian McKellar. Yeah.
然后我们切到我的角色，她只是瞪着他，表现得一点也不友善，伙计们。我在涂洗手液。我们在这一集中确实发现，我想《威尔和格蕾丝》非常吵，而且我喜欢哈里·康尼克二世。是的，你不是《威尔和格蕾丝》的粉丝，但你确实喜欢哈里·康尼克二世。给我发点哈里·康尼克。嗯，然后在10分8秒，梅雷迪思把一些安吉拉的洗手液挤到她的手上，然后舔掉了。
And then we cut to my character who's just glaring at him and being just not nice, you guys. And I'm applying hand sanitizer. And we do find out in this episode that I think Will and Grace is very loud and that I like Harry Connick Jr. Yeah you're not a fan of Will and Grace but you do like Harry Connick Jr. Send me some Harry Connick. Well then at 10 minutes 8 seconds Meredith pumps some of Angela's hand sanitizer into her hand and then licks it off.
本周我们的真实交易问题来自娜塔莎·拉赫曼。这是她想知道的。她说，当梅雷迪思被展示吃洗手液时，她实际上吃了什么？娜塔莎，我很高兴你问这个问题，因为我在看那一幕时实际上也想过同样的事情。事情是这样的。我想梅雷迪思认为她能从中得到快感。她，你知道，她认为里面有酒精，对吧？所以，是的，她就像，“我想吃点洗手液。”嗯，我昨天在和凯特·弗兰纳里发短信，我说：“凯特，你必须给我们透个底。洗手液里是什么？告诉我们所有细节。”她告诉你了吗？嗯，你猜怎么着。她就像，“我会给你留个言。”我当时想：“哦，好吧，更好。”
This week our real deal question comes from Natasha Rahman. Here's what she wants to know. She said, what did Meredith actually eat when she is shown eating the hand sanitizer? Natasha, I am so glad you asked this question because I actually wondered the same thing when I was watching the scene. Here's the thing. I think Merida thinks she can get a buzz off of it. She's, you know, she thinks there's alcohol in it, right? So, yeah, she's like, I want to have some hand sanitizer. Well, I was texting with Kate Flannery yesterday and I said, Kate, you've got to give us the low down. What was in the hand sanitizer? Tell us all the details. Did she tell you? Well, guess what she did. She was like, and I will leave you a message about it. And I was like, oh, okay, even better.
所以她给我留了言，她说我们可以在这里播放。所以萨姆，播放凯特的回答。嘿，大家好，我是凯特·弗兰纳里，我在这里回答《办公室女士》播客粉丝的一个精彩问题。我有一种预感，我知道这是谁问的。这是来自AOL的Big Tool 9吗？我想很久以前他问过我同样的问题。好吧，不管怎样，当梅雷迪思被展示吃洗手液时，她实际上吃了什么？所以他们实际上改变了瓶子里的东西。
So she left me a message and she said we can play it here. So Sam play Kate's answer. Hey everybody, it's Kate Flannery and I'm here to answer a fantastic question from one of the fans of the Office Ladies podcast. And I have a feeling I know who this is from. Is this from Big Tool 9 at AOL? I think he asked me the same question a long time ago. Okay, anyway, what did Meredith actually eat when she's shown eating the hand sanitizer? So they actually changed what was in the bottle.
他们放了加苏打水的明胶，所以它有气泡。所以它只是透明的明胶，但他们把它放回了最初装洗手液的同一个瓶子里，那是非常香的。所以当我舔掉手上的东西时，它尝起来像香水。所以有点恶心。
They put gelatin with club soda, so it had the bubbles. So it was just clear gelatin, but they put it back in the same bottle that the original hand sanitizer came in, which is very perfumey. So when I went to lick it off my hand, it tasted like perfume. So it was kind of gross.
我想我们可能拍了四五次。所以没有涉及廉价的快感。我的意思是，我是个大果冻迷，但我喜欢一点味道，我不特别喜欢香水的味道。不管怎样，那只是我的口味。谢谢你的提问。你确定这不是AOL的Big Tool 9吗？是的，我经常在网上收到不管是谁问的问题。好吧，祝一切顺利。爱你们，伙计们。呜呼！希望我们能在一起。凯特，谢谢。这让我笑了，凯特在这里。
And I think we did maybe four or five takes. So there was no cheap high involved. I mean I'm a big jello fan but I like a little flavor and I don't particularly like perfumey flavor. Anyway that's just my taste. Thank you for asking. Are you sure this wasn't Big Tool 9 at AOL? Yeah I get a lot of questions online from whoever that is. Okay all the best. Love you guys. Woohoo! Wish we were physically together. Kate, thank you. It just made me laugh that here's Kate.
凯特总是有个梗，你知道吗？所以我喜欢即使在回答这个问题时，她也有关于那个家伙的梗，那个Big Tool，不管是谁，一直给她写信。Big Tool 9。Big Tool 9。伙计们，得了吧。为什么他们不能把它放在一个冲洗过的瓶子里什么的？我不知道。我只是想说这就像一个两秒钟的笑话。
Kate always has a bit, you know? And so like, I love that even in answering this, she had her bit about the guy that Big Tool, whatever, who kept like writing into her. Big Tool 9. Big Tool 9. Guys, come on. Why couldn't they have put it in a bottle that had been rinsed out or something? I don't know. I just wanna say that this is like a two second joke.
就像这样。这不是一个连续的梗。她没有在办公室里到处看，这只是一个小小的时刻。它在剧本里。当我想到这样的时刻时，我只是想到为了让她吃点东西而进行的所有计划。
Like this is it. This is not a runner. She doesn't go around the office looking at, this was just like a little moment. It is in the script. And when I think of moments like this, I just think of all the planning that went in to making something for her to eat.
我实际上给菲尔·谢发了短信，我说：“菲尔，当你拿到剧本，有一个小小的笑话，它让你走上这条路时，是什么感觉？”他说，这些是他最喜欢的时刻，因为这是一个挑战，他读了之后就像：“好吧，是时候找到可食用的洗手液了。”
And I actually texted Phil Shea and I was like, Phil, what is it like when you get a script and there's this little tiny joke and it sends you down this road? And he said, these are his favorite moments because it's a challenge and that he read this and he was like, all right, time to find edible hand sanitizer.
我实际上给菲尔·谢伊发了短信，我说，菲尔，当你拿到剧本，看到里面有一个小小的笑话，然后它让你走上这条路时，是什么感觉？他说，这些是他最喜欢的时刻，因为这是一种挑战，他读到这里时心想，好吧，是时候去找可食用的洗手液了。
And I sort of found it interesting that they had to put like a sparkly like water like seltzer in it because I bet once they added the gelatin, there were no bubbles and hand sanitizer has bubbles. So that is like such a small, tiny amount of detail that they were like, nope, we didn't get it right. Let's add the seltzer. Well, I'll have you know, I noticed the bubbles and it really threw me because it made me think that Kate was really eating hand sanitizer, which I knew she
我觉得很有意思的是，他们必须在里面加点像气泡水或苏打水之类的东西，因为我敢打赌，一旦加了明胶，就不会有气泡了，而洗手液是有气泡的。所以这是一个非常微小的细节，他们当时觉得，不行，我们没弄对，加点苏打水吧。好吧，我得告诉你，我注意到了那些气泡，这真的让我很困惑，因为这让我以为凯特真的在吃洗手液，而我知道她
couldn't possibly, they would never make her do that. And I asked Phil Shea about that. And he said at first they tried just clear agave syrup, just like a clear agave, you know, cause it's thick and sweet, but no bubbles. You say syrup very Midwest-y. Syrup. How do you say it? Syrup? Syrup. No, no, no, no. I think what you mean is I say syrup correctly and you say syrup. Okay. All right. Like a southerner. And excuse me. I'm not saying it's good or bad. I'm just saying you are saying it incorrectly. Really quickly before we get off on a huge tangent of our syrup and syrup and syrup like debate. Kate told me that she's really proud of the fact that she did
不可能真的吃，他们绝不会让她那么做。我问过菲尔·谢伊这件事。他说起初他们只是试了透明的龙舌兰糖浆，你知道，因为糖浆又浓又甜，但没有气泡。你说“糖浆”（syrup）的时候很有中西部口音。Syrup。你是怎么说的？Syrup？Syrup。不，不，不，不。我想你的意思是，我说的syrup是对的，而你说的syrup是错的。好吧。好吧。像个南方人一样。抱歉。我不是说好坏，我只是说你发音不正确。在我们要陷入关于syrup和syrup的巨大争论之前，凯特很快地告诉我，她真的很自豪她
Kate told me that she's really proud of the fact that she did her stunts. She did a lot of her own stunts. The majority of all the things that you see that happens to Meredith, Kate did a pass at that. And so she was like, this was just another one of those. When I got the script, I was like, okay, what am I going to be licking? What is it? I don't think anyone in the cast was subjected to more stunts than Kate, actually. No, no one was. Maybe Steve, maybe Steve. But Kate, I think, is actually number one.
凯特告诉我，她真的很自豪她亲自完成了特技动作。她做了很多自己的特技。你在梅雷迪思身上看到的绝大多数事情，凯特都亲自尝试过。所以她当时就觉得，这只是其中之一。当我拿到剧本时，我就想，好吧，我要舔什么？是什么？其实我觉得剧组里没有人比凯特承受更多的特技了。不，没人比得上。也许史蒂夫，也许史蒂夫。但我觉得凯特其实是第一名。
I think she's number one. And she was a really good sport about it. And Kate, thank you so much for sending in that message. Thank you, Kate. Well, guys, there you have it. When you want the real deal on the office, where are your ladies? When you want the real deal on insurance like a good neighbor, State Farm is there. If you want to submit questions about a future episode, please head over to OfficeLadies.com slash real deal. If we pick your question as our real deal question, you win a swag bag of cool stuff including a signed office ladies mug. And thank you again, Natasha. All right, so now we're back.
我觉得她是第一名。她对此表现得非常大度。凯特，非常感谢你发来的那条信息。谢谢你，凯特。好了，伙计们，就是这样。当你想了解《办公室》的内幕时，女士们就在这里。当你想了解像好邻居State Farm那样的保险内幕时，他们就在那里。如果你想提交关于未来剧集的问题，请前往OfficeLadies.com/realdeal。如果我们选中你的问题作为我们的“真料”问题，你将赢得一个包含酷炫物品的礼包，包括一个签名的《办公室》女士马克杯。再次感谢你，娜塔莎。好了，现在我们回来了。
We're at 10 minutes, 37 seconds, and we get a real bird's eye view of Andy's temper because someone has put his calculator in Jell-O and he kind of freaks out. He does freak out. He kicks the trash can. Yeah. I'll have you know that was not in the script. And when I was texting with Ed, he
现在是10分37秒，我们看到了安迪脾气的真实写照，因为有人把他的计算器放进了果冻里，他有点抓狂了。他确实抓狂了。他踢了垃圾桶。是的。我得告诉你，那不在剧本里。当我和艾德发短信时，他
told me that they came up with that on the set. He remembered Mike Schurr being on set and throwing out a bunch of funny ideas. And in this moment, this was one of those moments where they were able to say like, okay, how much, how big of a reaction can Andy have to this jello thing? And he was like, how about I kick the trash can? They were like, try it. And it made it in. to this jello thing and he was like how about I kick the trash can they were like try it and it made it in and he was super excited because it was kind of like his first improv moment that made it in an episode. Yeah I loved I thought
告诉我那是他们在片场临时想出来的。他记得迈克·舒尔当时在片场，抛出了很多有趣的点子。在这一刻，这是他们能够说出“好吧，安迪对这个果冻事件能有多大的反应？”的时刻之一。他说，我踢垃圾桶怎么样？他们说，试试看。结果就用上了。对这个果冻事件能有多大的反应？他说，我踢垃圾桶怎么样？他们说，试试看。结果就用上了，他超级兴奋，因为这就像是他第一次即兴发挥并被剪进剧集里的时刻。是的，我很喜欢，我觉得
it was perfect and it really was like oh this guy is unhinged. Yeah. He's not okay. Well I noticed a really random thing over his shoulder when he starts talking about the calculator. On his computer, it says table of contents. I saw that too. I'm like, is Andy writing a book? Is he reading a book? What is he looking at?
这太完美了，真的让人觉得“哦，这家伙精神失常了”。是的。他不太正常。好吧，我注意到当他开始谈论计算器时，他肩膀后面有一个非常随机的东西。在他的电脑上，写着“目录”。我也看到了。我在想，安迪是在写书吗？他在看书吗？他在看什么？
Is it a manual? What is it? And I watched the deleted scenes. I thought maybe there might be some reference to it, but there wasn't. So I thought that was kind of interesting. I'm like, what is that about? Remains a mystery. Mystery.
是手册吗？是什么？我看了删减片段。我以为可能会有相关的参考，但并没有。所以我认为这很有趣。我在想，那是什么意思？依然是个谜。谜。
So now we're going to go back again to the Scranton branch. Jan has arrived. Yeah, they had to call in the big guns because things are going off the rails here. So Jan is not happy. No. Toby explains that now Oscar is basically feeling discriminated against by everyone in the office, particularly Angela.
所以现在我们要回到斯克兰顿分部了。简到了。是的，他们不得不请出大人物，因为这里的事情已经失控了。所以简很不高兴。不。托比解释说，现在奥斯卡基本上觉得办公室里的每个人都在歧视他，尤其是安吉拉。
Yeah. And Michael needs to do something about it. Yeah. So Michael calls Oscar into his office. Oh, man. And Oscar says to Michael, Am I the first gay man that you've ever known? Yeah. Is this, is this what is happening right now?
是的。迈克尔需要对此采取行动。是的。所以迈克尔把奥斯卡叫进了他的办公室。天哪。奥斯卡对迈克尔说，我是你认识的第一个同性恋吗？是的。这是，这是现在正在发生的事情吗？
Yeah. And they're, they seem like they might be about to have this very productive heart to heart when Pam comes in to announce that Dwight is looking at gay porn on his computer. Because that's what Michael asked him to do. This is how Michael thinks he's going to problem solve. Like what? Yeah. First of all, you shouldn't be looking at pornography at work.
是的。他们看起来好像要进行一次非常富有成效的交心，这时帕姆进来宣布德怀特正在电脑上看同性恋色情片。因为那是迈克尔让他做的。这就是迈克尔认为他能解决问题的方式。什么？是的。首先，你不应该在工作时看色情片。
At any pornography. At any pornography. Why would he ever think this is acceptable to try to remedy a situation? Oh my gosh. Michael, Michael, Michael. Because Michael says, hey, there is nothing wrong with it. Gay porn, straight porn, it's all good. Yeah, it's all good. And then- At work. At work. What is happening?
任何色情片。任何色情片。他怎么会认为这是解决问题的可接受方式？天哪。迈克尔，迈克尔，迈克尔。因为迈克尔说，嘿，这没什么错。同性恋色情片，异性恋色情片，都挺好的。是的，都挺好的。然后——在工作时。在工作时。发生了什么？
So they're all gathered around Dwight's desk. And anyway, Oscar walks up and he's like, what are you guys doing? And then Angela has a really snarky line where she's like, watching some of your friends. Oh, yeah. So snarky. And he kind of shoves past her.
所以他们都聚集在德怀特的办公桌旁。总之，奥斯卡走过来，他说，你们在干什么？然后安吉拉说了一句非常刻薄的话，她说，看你的一些朋友。哦，是的。太刻薄了。他从她身边挤了过去。
Oh, lady, we had a fan question about that. Anthony Giuretano said, how much choreography was involved in Oscar pushing you, Angela? Was this planned? Here's the thing. It really does look like he kind of shoves me aside, but the direction we were given is that my character is really
哦，女士，我们有一个粉丝问过这个问题。安东尼·朱雷塔诺问，奥斯卡推你的时候有多少编排，安吉拉？这是计划好的吗？事情是这样的。看起来他确实把我推开了，但我们得到的指导是，我的角色在这一刻非常夸张地表现出戏剧性，就像你看足球比赛时，有人轻轻碰了一下，他们就大喊大叫，“哦，天哪”。这就是肯指导我的方式，奥斯卡只是轻轻擦过我。而我会表现得，“哦，别碰我”。你知道，是的。好吧，这就是我在上一集留下的悬念小片段里提到的，当时我说，好吧，这就是我去找格雷格的时候。还有另一句台词，我不记得是什么了，但大概是
playing up the drama of this moment, almost like when you watch like a soccer match and someone barely gets nudged and they have the big ball like, oh, yes. That's that's how Ken directed me, that Oscar would just really barely brush by me. And I'd be like, oh, don't touch me. You know, yes. Well, this is what I was talking about in the cliffhanger little moment I left in the last episode where I was like, okay, this is when I went to Greg. There was another line and I can't remember what it was but it was
类似“我觉得耶稣会对你感到失望”之类的话。我去找格雷格说，格雷格，我是去教堂长大的，我也去教堂，那不是我从耶稣那里得到的信息。我不认为安吉拉·马丁会那样想。我是说，她可以随心所欲地评判别人，但我不认为她是那样想的。她的那种方式，她那种紧张和爱评判人的样子
something like sort of like, well I think Jesus would be disappointed in you or something like that. I just went to Greg and I was like, Greg, I grew up going to church and I go to church and that's just not the message I received about Jesus. And I just don't think that's how Angela Martin would think. I mean, she can be judgy all she wants, but I don't think that's how she thinks. Her way that she is, how she's kind of uptight and judgy
所有这些都与她的宗教信仰是分开的。我想这就是你想做的。你想把它们分开。是的。格雷格非常大度。格雷格说，安吉拉，天哪，非常感谢你和我分享这些。这完全不是我的本意。我们只是想要一个高潮时刻，让奥斯卡推开你，这样我们就能有一个渐强，让迈克尔出来说“所有人去会议室”。所以他说，是的，我们会想出另一句台词。非常感谢你和我分享这些。所以我感到如释重负。
and all of that is separate from her religion. And I think that's what you were wanting to do. You were wanting to separate it. Yeah. And Greg was so gracious. Greg was like, Angela, oh my God, thank you so much for, you know, sharing that with me. It's totally not what I intended. We just wanted a heightened moment so that Oscar shoves past you so that we can sort of have this crescendo that makes Michael come out and say everyone to the conference room. So he was like, yeah, we'll we'll come up with a different line. And thank you so much for sharing that with me. So I felt like relief.
我也觉得我妈妈可以看这一集而不会感到不安，太不安了。我当时想，哦，不。好吧，妈妈。是的。她还是很刻薄。她还是很刻薄和尖酸。但是，但是是的，我真的很感激格雷格听取了我的意见。所以迈克尔现在受够了。他就像是，好吧，各位，我不在乎你是谁或者你发生了什么。去会议室。我们要谈谈这件事。
And I also felt like my mom could watch the episode without getting upset, too upset. I was like, oh, no. All right, mom. Yes. She's still snarky. She's still really mean and snarky. But, but yeah, I was really appreciative to Greg for hearing me out. So Michael has now had it. Like he's like, okay, everyone, I don't care who you are or what's going on with you. Get in the conference room. We're going to talk this out.
是的。我觉得这是一个休息的好地方。当每个人走进会议室时，我们将休息一下，然后回来录制新的视频。我觉得这是一个休息的好地方。我觉得这是一个休息的好地方。我觉得这是一个休息的好地方。我觉得这是一个休息的好地方。
Yes. And I think this is a good place for a break. Every as everyone walks into the conference room, we will take a break and we will come back with a new video. And I think that's a good place for a break. And I think that's a good place for a break. And I think that's a good place for a break. And I think that's a good place for a break.
我觉得这是一个休息的好地方。我觉得这是一个休息的好地方。我觉得这是一个休息的好地方。我觉得这是一个休息的好地方。我觉得这是一个休息的好地方。我觉得这是一个休息的好地方。我觉得这是一个休息的好地方。我觉得这是一个休息的好地方。我觉得这是一个休息的好地方。我觉得这是一个休息的好地方。我觉得这是一个休息的好地方，我觉得这是一个休息的好地方。
And I think that's a good place for a break. And I think that's a good place for a break. And I think that's a good place for a break. And I think that's a good place for a break. And I think that's a good place for a break. And I think that's a good place for a break. And I think that's a good place for a break. And I think that's a good place for a break. And I think that's a good place for a break. And I think that's a good place for a break. And I think that's a good place for a break, and I think this is a good place for a break.
当每个人走进会议室时，我们将休息一下，然后回来讲述会议室里发生的一切，那可是很多事。好了，我们回来了。我们在会议室里。迈克尔正在主持关于同性恋意味着什么的讨论。这包括这一集中我最喜欢的台词之一，就是你的，安吉拉，当迈克尔问谁应该是我们社会的法官和陪审团时。法官和陪审团。他说，你说得很有道理。我喜欢那个。
As everyone walks into the conference room, we will take a break and we will come back with everything that happens in the conference room, which is a lot. All right, so we're back. We're in the conference room. Michael is leading a discussion about what it means to be gay. This includes one of my favorite lines from this episode, which is yours, Angela, when Michael asks who should be the judges and juries of our society. The judges and the juries. And he says, you're making a good point. I love that.
这个会议室场景也有一些很棒的切入镜头。这是克里德最喜欢的谈话片段之一。是的。他在演播室里为我们现场表演过。在60年代，我和许多许多女人做过爱，经常是在户外，在雨中和泥里。可能有个男人溜进来了。没法知道。是的，没法知道。没法知道。所以这是克里德最喜欢的谈话片段之一。我喜欢它。我们还了解到，天哪，我们了解到菲利斯订婚了。
This conference room scene has some great cutaways as well. And it is Creed's, one of his favorite talking heads happens. Yes. He's done it for us live in studio. In the 60s, I made love to many, many women, often outdoors in the rain and the mud. It's possible a man slipped in. There'd be no way of knowing. Yes, no way of knowing. No way of knowing. So this is one of Creed's favorite talking heads. I love it. We also learned, oh my gosh, we learned that Phyllis is engaged.
是的，菲利斯，这是菲利斯订婚的消息被揭露的时候，因为德怀特说菲利斯可能是个女同性恋。她说，其实，我要和鲍勃·万斯结婚了。我们都说，什么？我们都非常兴奋。她没有宣布，也没有告诉我们。这就是我们所有人发现的方式。然后她炫耀她的戒指，对吧？
Yes, Phyllis, this is when it's revealed that Phyllis is engaged because Dwight says Phyllis might be a lesbian. And she's like, actually, I'm getting married to Bob Vance. And we're all like, what? And we're all very excited. She didn't announce it or tell us. This is how we all find out. Then she shows her ring off, right?
我们正在看。珍娜，菲利斯的戒指是簇状戒指吗？安吉拉，我觉得是簇状的。什么？鲍勃·万斯。鲍勃·万斯应该给她买个大钻戒。我不相信。我不相信。
And we're looking over. Jenna, is Phyllis' ring a cluster ring? Angela, I think it's a cluster. What? And Bob Vance. Bob Vance should get her a big rock. I don't believe it. I don't believe it.
我不相信。我想在以后的剧集里你会看到它被换掉了。我想是的。我记得她有一个很大的戒指，我们当时说，哦，鲍勃·万斯，是吧？我们还拿它开玩笑，但在这一幕里，它看起来像个簇状戒指。
I don't believe it. And I think you're gonna see in later episodes, it gets switched. I think it does. I remember her having a big honking ring and we're like, ooh, Bob Vance, huh? And like we did bits about it, but in this shot, it looked like a cluster ring.
它是簇状的。我是说，鲍勃·万斯是个很爱炫耀的人。他会给他的女士买一个大大的单颗钻石。是的，他会。是的，他会。好吧，我们需要追踪一下。菲利斯在这里有一句台词，我非常喜欢，因为我喜欢每一次
It's a cluster. I mean, Bob Vance is a very showy guy. He's gonna give his lady a big old solitaire diamond. Yes, he is. Yes, he is. Okay, we need to track that. And Phyllis has, you know, a line in here that I love because I love every single time,
菲利斯提醒我们所有人她和迈克尔是高中同学。我为之着迷。我为之着迷。你知道安吉拉，那一点让我很好奇，因为我在想，我不觉得菲利斯和史蒂夫是同龄人。我实际上去了维基百科查了一下，史蒂夫·卡瑞尔和菲利斯·史密斯在现实生活中相差10岁。但尽管如此，我喜欢这个梗。这是一个非常有趣的梗，迈克尔讨厌它，但我们也了解到迈克尔在高中时穿西装打领带，配着相称的漂亮袜子和漂亮袜子。我喜欢那个
Phyllis reminds us all that she and Michael went to high school together. I live for it. I live for it. You know Angela that one got me curious because I was like I don't think that Phyllis and Steve are the same age. I actually went to Wikipedia and I looked it up and there is a 10-year age difference between Steve Carell and Phyllis Smith in real life. But nonetheless, I love this runner. It's a very funny runner and Michael hates it, but we also learned that Michael in high school wore suits and ties and matching fancy socks and fancy socks. I love that
背景故事。是的，会议室里还有一个时刻，迈克尔说我们都是“同性恋”（homos）。智人（homo sapiens）。帕姆，这让帕姆笑了，她咯咯笑着转向旁边的人，但那是瑞安。瑞安什么反应都没有。不。什么都没有。你会注意到在这一集中，当我们切回斯坦福会议室里的吉姆时，他正在回忆和帕姆在一起的会议室，就像帕姆正在回忆和吉姆在一起的会议室一样。他们没有人可以看，无法分享这种体验。我知道。他们的人不在了。是的，他们的人不在了。所以迈克尔就开始跑题了。
backstory. Yeah, there's also a moment in the conference room where michael says we're all homos. homo sapiens. and pam, this is, this makes pam laugh and she giggles and turns to the person next to her but it's ryan. and ryan gives you nothing. no. nothing. And you'll notice in this episode when we cut back to Jim in the conference room at Stanford, he is having memories of conference rooms with Pam, just like Pam is having her memories of conference rooms with Jim. And they have no one to look at to sort of share the experience with. I know. That's what they were to is gone. Yeah, their person is gone. So then Michael goes on this tangent.
他只是说，你知道，同性婚姻是不合法的。有多少异性恋男人希望这适用于他们？他说，奥斯卡，你真幸运，同性婚姻是不合法的。我觉得我在某种单口喜剧里见过这个。我觉得这个概念。是的，我觉得迈克尔可能借鉴了他看过的某些喜剧演员的段子，我敢打赌外面的丈夫们希望……我觉得迈克尔在表演他的段子。我觉得你说得太对了。事情是这样的。当我听到那个时，
He just says, you know, gay marriage isn't legal. And how many straight men wished that applied to them? He's like, you're so lucky, Oscar, that gay marriage isn't legal. I feel like I've seen this like in sort of a stand up routine. I feel like this concept. Yeah, I feel like Michael has like pulled some of his comedians that he's seen sort of do this bit that I bet husbands out there wish that I feel like Michael is doing his bit. I think you're so right on that. Here's the thing. When I heard that,
我其实心想，天哪，同性婚姻是不合法的。现在是合法的，对吧？但是的，我们是在2007年拍摄的，当时同性婚姻是不合法的。安吉拉，这让我跑题了。你去哪了？你去哪了？安吉拉，我进行了一次深度挖掘。哦哦。萨姆，能给我一个深度挖掘吗？你听到了吗，安吉拉？我听到了。听起来像马桶冲水的声音。哦，亲爱的。好吧。不，那是我也在对同性婚姻的历史进行深度挖掘。等一下。你和萨姆交换关于音效的电子邮件吗？因为我觉得你和萨姆之间有一些我没有的速记，我不会说“萨姆，播放那个……”。萨姆，给我一个鸟叫声，咔咔。
I actually thought to myself, oh my god, gay marriage wasn't legal. Like it is legal now, right? But yes, we shot this back in 2007 and gay marriage was not legal. Angela, this sent me on a tangent. Where did you go? Where did you go? Angela, I went on a deep dive. Uh-oh. Sam, can I get a deep dive please? Did you hear that Angela? I did. It sounded like a toilet being flushed. Oh dear. Okay. No, that's me also doing a deep dive into the history of gay marriage. Wait one second. Do you and Sam trade emails about sound effects? Because I feel like you have some shorthand with Sam that I don't have where I'm not like Sam hit the full Mendy. Sam, give me a bird going, kaka.
就像，萨姆，给我一个啤酒的声音。也许我们有，安，也许我们有。也许萨姆和我时不时会交换音效邮件。如果你想知道，我也录了这个。你有一个深度，你有一个挖掘。你把它们放在一起，就是一个深度挖掘。那是你的孩子吗？
Like, Sam, give me a beer, like sound. Maybe we do, Anne, maybe we do. Maybe Sam and I trade sound effects emails from time to time. If you wanna know, I also recorded this. You got a deep, you got a dive. You put them together, get a deep dive. Are those your children?
那是我儿子。他为我制作了一个深度挖掘的音效。我喜欢那个。我可能比你的马桶冲水声更喜欢那个。好吧，听着，重点是我对同性婚姻的历史进行了深度挖掘，我要把它抛给你。你准备好了吗？好吧，我想抛给我吧。好吧。所以在2000年，20年前，
That's my son. He made me a deep dive sting. I like that. I might like that better than your toilet flush. Well, listen, the point is I did a deep dive on the history of gay marriage and I'm going to throw it at you. Are you ready? Okay, I guess throw it at me. All right. So in the year 2000, 20 years ago,
佛蒙特州是美国第一个允许同性伴侣建立民事结合的地方。第一个将同性婚姻合法化的州是2003年的马萨诸塞州。看看你。看看你，梅斯。看看你。哦，看看他们。哦，我做得好吗？那好吗？看看他们。我不知道，亲爱的。我不知道那是什么。他们在马萨诸塞州太聪明了。他们超级聪明。好吧，继续。非常聪明。非常聪明。非常聪明。干得好。好吧。好吧，所以马萨诸塞州是第一个将同性婚姻合法化的州。宾夕法尼亚州是东北地区最后一个承认同性婚姻的州。直到2014年5月州最高法院裁决后，它才在那里合法化。
Vermont was the first place in the country of the United States to allow civil unions for gay couples. The first state to legalize gay marriage was Massachusetts in 2003. Look at you. Look at you mess. Look at you go. Oh look at them go. Oh did I do a good one? Was that good? Look at them go. I don't know honey. I don't know what that was. They were so smart in Massachusetts. They're so super smart. All right so go on. Wicked smart. Wicked smart. Wicked smart. Way to go. All right. All right so Massachusetts was the first state to legalize gay marriage. Pennsylvania was the last state in the northeastern region to recognize same-sex marriage. It did not become legal there until a state supreme court ruling in May of 2014.
直到2015年6月26日，它才在全美50个州合法化。有一个最高法院的裁决。那个决定推翻了对同性婚姻的禁令，在所有50个州将其合法化，并规定所有州都必须承认外州的结婚证。女士，那才五年前？这让我感到震惊。总之，这就是我的深度挖掘，伙计们。当我听到他说那句话时，我变得超级好奇。是的。因为现在它是法律，但曾经有一段时间它不是，我想了解更多。所以就是这样。就是这样。她在这里进行关于你的阿尔法子宫的深度挖掘……是的。这里是
And it did not become legal in all 50 United States until June 26th, 2015. There was a supreme court ruling. That decision struck down bans on same sex marriage, legalized it in all 50 states, and said that all states had to honor out-of-state marriage licenses. Lady, that was only five years ago? That is astonishing to me. Anyway, that was my deep dive, guys. I got super curious when I heard him say that. yeah. because now it is the law but there was a time when it was not and I wanted to learn more about it. so there you have it. there you have it. she's here for the deep dives on your alpha womb and... yes. here are
到目前为止我深度挖掘的事情。你能在卡本代尔的加油站买到山药吗？你真的深度挖掘了那个。什么是阿尔法子宫？是的。同性婚姻。现在，别忘了，你确实跟踪了一个大学阿卡贝拉合唱团，而且你知道他们的排练时间表。所以别忘了。天哪。我在这一集里做了两次深度挖掘。天哪。我真的贡献良多。
the things I've deep dived so far. Can you get yams at a gas station in Carbondale? You really deep dived on that. What is an alpha womb? Yeah. Gay marriage. And now, well, don't forget, you did stalk a college a cappella group and you know their rehearsal schedule. So let's not forget. Oh, my gosh. I did two deep dives in this episode. Oh, my God. I'm really contributing.
我正在贡献。好吧，伙计们，这次会议室会议进行得不顺利。奥斯卡对托比说，我觉得我甚至不能在这里工作了。这是我一生中最糟糕的一天。他起身离开，迈克尔拦住了他。现在我们要进行
I'm contributing. Okay, so guys, this conference room meeting is not going well. Oscar says to Toby, I don't even think I can work here anymore. This is the worst day of my life. He gets up to leave and Michael stops him. And now we are going to have
最辉煌的互动。所以我们不能不提这个场景中尴尬而又令人敬畏的精彩之处，没有奥斯卡·努涅斯。所以，我们给他打了电话。是的，我们打了。我们录了下来，这就是它。嗨，奥斯卡。嗨，珍娜。嗨，安吉拉。哦，这太有趣了，奥斯卡。你知道这是什么吗，珍娜？什么？
the most glorious interaction. So we could not talk about the awkwardly cringy awesomeness of this scene without Oscar Nunez. So y'all we called him. Yeah we did. We recorded it and here it is. Hi, Oscar. Hi, Jenna. Hi, Angela. Oh, this is so fun, Oscar. You know what this is, Jenna? What?
这是“难以置信的”（un-be-lie-va-val）。是的，这真是难以置信。这就是我想要笑的时候所做的。我看《办公室》，但我看花絮。我翻遍了所有季，那是让我笑得最厉害的片段之一。我喜欢那个。你知道，伊莎贝尔喜欢花絮。我也喜欢。我喜欢花絮。我只记得我们无法完成那个场景。不，费舍尔。你是煽动者。你无法控制自己。
It's un-be-lie-va-val. Yes, it is unbelievable. That's what I do all when I want to get a laugh. I watch the office, but I watch the bloopers. I go through all the seasons and that's one of the takes that makes me laugh so much. I love that. You know, Isabel loves the bloopers. I mean too. I love the bloopers. I just remember we could not get through that scene. No Fisher. You were the instigator. You couldn't get it together.
我知道。对不起。对不起，你们太搞笑了。这发生了。而且我们从来没有一起做过谈话片段。所以那种新奇感也是。是的。好吧，奥斯卡。这太好了。奥斯卡，你从不笑场。
I know. I'm sorry. I'm sorry, you guys are funny. It happens. And also we never, ever got to do Talking Heads together. So it was just like the novelty of that too. Yeah. Well, Oscar. It was so good. Oscar, you never break.
你从不笑场。你知道，我在看，我想是第四季，艾德·赫尔姆斯让我笑喷了，因为他做了太多鬼脸，而且依然很稳。赫尔姆斯在其中一个花絮里让我笑喷了。好吧，但真的，我觉得我们可以用一只手数出你在九年里笑场的次数。九年里。我给奥斯卡起的绰号是“雕像”，因为他从不笑场。
You never break. You know, I was watching, I think it's season four, Ed Helms made me crack up because he just he mugs so much his funny faces and it's still grounded. And Helms made me crack up in one of the bloopers. Well, but truly, I feel like we could we could count on one hand the number of times you broke in the whole nine years in nine years. My nickname for Oscar was the statue because he never broke.
是的。好吧，奥斯卡，幸好你是史蒂夫在《同性恋女巫狩猎》里的搭档。房间里的其他人都笑场了。你没有。谢天谢地，因为这样他们才有可用的镜头。因为珍娜，我忍住了。我知道你的信号，因为我和你一起坐在会计部。所以布莱恩做了那个茶壶。我们谈过那个，他开始笑的时候，他会试图通过吹嘴角的空气来掩盖它。
Yeah. Well, Oscar, it's a good thing that you were Steve's scene partner in Gay Witch Hunt. Everybody else in the room broke. You did not. And thank goodness, because then they had usable takes. Because Jenna, I stifled it. I know your tells because I sat back with you in accounting. So Brian did the tea kettle. We've talked about that, how he, as he would start to laugh, he would like try to hide it by blowing out the corner of his mouth.
我称之为茶壶。他会说，是的，是的。像那样。没错。但你做了一个微小的，像咕哝声。但没人知道你会发出像“啊”的声音。像那样。所以我现在需要回去看那个场景。我们会讲到的，但我得看看能不能听到。好吧，但在我们进入那个场景之前，奥斯卡，我们每次有嘉宾上节目，我们都会问他们关于你是如何加入《办公室》的。你的试镜过程是怎样的？你的故事是什么？
I called it the tea kettle. He'd be like, yes, yes. Like that. That's right. But you did this tiny minuscule, like a grunt. But no one knew you would go like a. Like that. So now I need to go back and watch that scene. We'll get to it, but I want to see if I can hear it. Okay, but before we get into the scene, Oscar, we start whenever we have a guest on the show, we ask them a little bit about how you came to be on the office. Like what was your audition process? Like what's your story?
好吧，嗯，好吧，我会从试镜开始，因为我不想……因为你和我以前就认识，我甚至不知道我们是在Groundlings还是什么地方认识的。Groundlings，奥斯卡。好吧，奥斯卡和我认识很久了。但珍娜，就像你谈论约翰那样，这是在你给人们发短信或知道他们生活中发生的事情之前。没有社交媒体。所以我根本不知道奥斯卡试镜了，他也不知道我试镜了。
Well, um, well, okay, I'll just start with the audition because I don't want to because you and I knew each other from before and I don't even know when the groundlings or something where we met. The groundlings Oscar. Okay, Oscar and I had known each other forever. But Jenna, like how you were talking about with John, like this was before you texted people or knew information about what was going on in their lives. There was no social media. So I had no idea that Oscar auditioned and he didn't know that I auditioned.
直到我第一天走进片场，我走到他们告诉我的会计部坐下，奥斯卡就在那里，我才知道他得到了这个角色。我当时想，天哪，奥斯卡！她没开玩笑。就像电影一样，像《当哈利遇上莎莉》之类的。我们不知道这一点，不是通过八卦，
And I didn't know that he got it until the day I walked on set the first day and I walk over to accounting where they told me I was sitting and there's Oscar. And I'm like, oh my God, Oscar! She's not kidding. It's like a movie, like a Harry Met Sally or something. We did not know this, not through gossip,
也不是通过阅读文书。我们都走进片场，我们穿着戏服，我当时想，你在这里干什么？她说，你在这里干什么？我说，哦不，我们在同一个节目里。我们太兴奋了，因为我们做过一个素描喜剧节目。我们认识，天哪，奥斯卡，大概15年前？
not through reading paperwork. We both walked on the set and there we were in wardrobe and I'm like, what are you doing here? And she's like, what are you doing here? I'm like, oh no, we're on the same show. We were so excited because we had done a sketch comedy show. We had met, God, Oscar, what, like 15 years earlier?
看到朋友的感觉真好，你会说，我们在同一个节目里。这真的发生了，但它确实发生了。而且不仅仅是在同一个节目里。你们就像队友。我们在同一个部门。我们在同一张桌子。你知道吗？
It's such a great feeling to see a friend, and you're like, we're on the same show. That really happens, but it does happen. But not just on the same show. You guys were like teammates. We were in the same department. We were in the same desk. You know?
所以更好。说到这个，奥斯卡，你是试镜会计的角色吗？是的，他们需要额外的人。他们给了我文稿去读。那是普通的办公室事务。好的。我的经纪人布鲁斯说，这是为《办公室》准备的。我说，嗯，那听起来不错。我喜欢英国版的《办公室》。
So even better. And speaking of that, Oscar, did you audition for the role of an accountant? Yes, they needed extra people. They gave me copy to read. And it was a general office stuff. OK. And my manager, Bruce, is like, it's for the office. And I'm like, well, that sounds good. And I love the British office.
但我以为。我们会拍试播集，然后它不会被选中。那是我的感觉。我太怀疑了。我想我们都有那种感觉。不在乎。但我喜欢这个节目。我喜欢瑞奇·热维斯。我说，哦，它很棒。但我们不会做得很好。我当时就是这么想的。我们不会做得很好，别兴奋。奥斯卡，别兴奋。
But I I thought. We'll do the pilot and it won't get picked up. That was my feeling. I was so skeptical. I think we all felt that way. Over it. But I love the show. I love the Rick of your base. And I'm like, oh, it's great. But we're not going to do it justice. That's what I was like. We're not going to do just don't get excited. Oscar, don't get excited.
所以，我想这就是我表现好的原因，因为我不在乎。然后他们说，好吧，让我们兴奋起来。我想这就是我表现好的原因，因为我不在乎。然后他们说，让我们来参加复试。然后复试，我想一定是写好的。但我去了，我想，三次，或者也许四次，三次是肯定的。最后一次是即兴表演。我说，好的，我真的很喜欢这个，因为我可以即兴表演。因为我当时就在Groundlings。
So and I think that's why I did well, because I didn't care. And then they're like, well, let's get excited. And I think that's why I did well, because I didn't care. And then they're like, well, let's come in for a callback. And then the callback, I think it must have been scripted. But I went in, I think, three times, or maybe four, three for sure. And then the last one was improv. And I was like, OK, I really like this, because I can improv. Because I was literally in the ground legs of it.
所以我即兴表演到了最后。而且，我度过了一段非常美好的时光，试图保持低调，不要太疯狂。然后我的经纪人打电话说，你得到了。我稍微兴奋了一点，但仍然没有辞掉我的日常工作。我在做餐饮和保姆，直到我们被选中拍摄这一季，我才辞职。然后弗兰纳里和我同时辞职了。我们看着对方，我们说，现在？她说，现在。是的。
So I improved to the live long day. And, I had really good time and tried to keep it close to the vest and not go too crazy. And then my manager called and said, you got it. And I got a little bit more excited, but still did not quit my day job. I was catering and babysitting and did not quit until we got picked up for the season. And then Flannery and I quit at the same time. We looked at each other, we're like, now? And she's like, now. Yeah.
现在就做吧。我说，好吧，让我们做吧。我们都辞职了。我们说，呜，自由落体。你辞掉了餐饮和保姆工作，凯特辞掉了服务员工作。没错。她可爱的经纪人说，每个人都祝她好运，她的经纪人说，你会回来的。
Let's do it now. I'm like, all right, let's do it. And we both quit. We're like, woo, free falling. You quit catering and babysitting and Kate quit being a waitress. That's right. And her lovely manager said, everyone wished her well and her manager said, you'll be back.
她说，哦，谢谢你。好吧，让我们谈谈这个场景。好吧，奥斯卡，这是迈克尔开始提议拥抱你的场景。你知道，你很沮丧，你说，我要走了。迈克尔说，来吧，我要给你一个拥抱，试图表明他完全接受奥斯卡是同性恋。但这最终导致史蒂夫亲吻了你的嘴唇，这不是剧本里的。
She's like, oh, thank you for that. All right, let's talk about this scene. All right, Oscar, this is the scene where Michael starts by offering to hug you. You know, you're upset, you're like, I'm out of here. And Michael's like, come on, I'm gonna give you a hug in an attempt to show that he's totally OK with Oscar being gay. But this ended up with Steve kissing you on the lips, which was not scripted.
嗯，这很疯狂，因为迈克尔，就像，完全冒犯了你。你觉得被侮辱了。你想离开。然后，然后你意识到你觉得被侮辱了。你想离开。然后。然后你意识到你伤了迈克尔的心。所以你说，好吧，伙计，过来。现在你，你在安慰迈克尔，他热泪盈眶。这根本不应该在这一刻发生。这根本不应该在工作场所发生。好吧，奥斯卡，我有《同性恋女巫狩猎》的剧本，
Well, it's crazy because Michael, like, completely offends you. And you're like, you feel insulted. You want to leave. Then then you realize you're like, you feel insulted. You want to leave then. Then you realize you've broken Michael's heart. And so you're like, okay, buddy, come here. Now you're, you're comforting Michael and he's like tearing up. It just like none of this should be happening in the moment. None of this should be happening in a workplace. Well, Oscar, I have the script from Gay Witch Hunt,
我查了一下，这是最初的剧本。因为我很好奇，因为我知道最终播出的版本是即兴表演。所以最初，他最初他拥抱你，然后他本应该去亲吻，但他退缩了，本应该亲吻你的额头之类的。但我记得坐在那个房间里，当史蒂夫说那句台词，“我希望你们把这个刻在脑子里”。那一刻。我们知道那是即兴表演。是的，
and I looked it up, and here is what was originally scripted. Because I was curious, because I knew that what ended up airing was an improv. So originally, he originally he hugs you, and then he was supposed to go in for a kiss, but he chickens out and is supposed to like kiss you on the forehead or something. But I remember sitting in that room and when Steve said the line, I want you to burn this into your brains. That was the moment. We knew that was improv. Yeah,
那不是剧本里的。史蒂夫现在脑子里在想什么？奥斯卡，对我来说，作为一个观众，我说观众，是因为我，我只是坐在会议室里作为一个观众。那句台词是我知道我们已经转入一条全新道路的时刻。对你来说是什么？你还记得你当时想“等等，发生了什么”吗？我有，我有时间处理它。但在那一刻，我
that was not scripted. What does Steve have in his head right now? And Oscar, to me as an audience member, and I'm saying audience member, like, because I was, I was just sitting in the conference room as an audience member. That line was the moment when I knew we had taken a turn on to a totally new road. What was it for you? Do you remember like when you were like, wait, what's going on? I've had I've had time to process it. But at the moment, I
想我们拍了三四次。拥抱的方式不多，就像你说的拥抱那样。然后，然后这一条，他，他进来了。我当时想，哦，他，他真的让我措手不及。他越来越近，哦，他真的让我措手不及。他越来越近，他的鼻子离我的鼻子越来越近。我在想，我在想，好吧，我不知道发生了什么
think we did three or four takes. Not a lot with hugging with that the way you're saying with the hugging. And then and then this particular take, he's he's coming in. And I'm like, oh, he's gonna he really caught me off guard. He's coming in closer and closer and, oh, he's gonna, he really caught me off guard. He's coming in closer and closer and his nose is getting closer to my nose. And I'm thinking, I'm thinking, well, I don't know what's happening
所以我只是站在这里，因为他要拥抱我。我在想，选一边。你知道当你拥抱某人时，珍妮，你必须向左或向右。是的。我在想，选一边，选一边，选一边。我当时想，哦不，他没选一边。
so I'm just gonna stand here because he's gonna hug me. And I'm thinking, pick a side. You know when you hug someone, Jenny, you have to go left or right. Yeah. And I'm like, pick a side, pick a side, pick a side. And I'm like, oh no, he's not picking a side.
他离得这么近。我当时想，他没选一边。然后他过来亲吻了一下，我们的嘴唇碰到了。然后那一刻，笑声从我的胃里涌出来，我忍住了。我还听到观众席里有很多咯咯笑和窃笑。
He's this close. I'm like, he's not picking a side. And then he came in for a sweet, sweet kiss and our lips touched. And then that's when like this laugh came from my stomach and I stopped it. And I also heard a lot of giggling and snickering from the peanut gallery.
我当时想，哦，我希望摄像机……好吧，没关系，因为那是反应。无论发生什么都在发生。然后他停止亲吻我，我当时想，哦，我希望摄像机……好吧，没关系，因为那是反应。无论发生什么都在发生。然后他停止亲吻我，我当时想，好吧，保持角色。我说，谢谢，我想。我不知道为什么。好吧，他有一句很棒的台词。
And I'm like, oh, I hope the camera's, well, it doesn't matter because that's the reaction. Whatever's happening is happening. And then he stopped kissing me and I'm like, oh, I hope the camera is, well, it doesn't matter because that's the reaction. Whatever's happening is happening. And then he stopped kissing me and I'm like, okay, stay in character. And I'm like, I said, thank you, I think. I don't know why. Well, he has this great line.
他有一句很棒的台词，嗯，首先，你即兴发挥了一句很棒的台词，奥斯卡，你说“我们不必这样做”。他说，“是的，我们必须”。是的，我们必须。好吧，你即兴发挥了一句很棒的台词，奥斯卡，你说“我们不必这样做”。他说，“是的，我们必须”。然后在他即兴发挥了这句台词后，他就像是，在那里，我猜就像是，他是英雄，我们仍然……他是英雄，他做到了，他做到了，他做到了，他把我从壁橱里拖了出来，我在那里本来很开心。好吧，让我惊讶的是，当你看到我们所有人的反应时，我们只是在实时反应。然而我们似乎也在角色中，除了BJ。我告诉你，BJ在那个时刻转过身去，当他坐在我旁边时，因为他开始
He has this great line where, well, first of all, you improvised a great line, Oscar, where you're like, we don't have to do this. And he's like, yes, we do. Yes, we do. Well, you improvise a great line Oscar where you're like we don't have to do this Yes, we do and then after he improvised this line where he was like there I guess like it's he's the hero and we're still He's the hero he did it he did it he did he dragged me out of the closet where I was perfectly happy Well, the thing that amazes me is that when you see all of our reactions, we were just reacting in real time. And yet we also are seem to be reacting in character except for BJ. I'll tell you, BJ turns away in that moment when he's sitting next to me because he started
笑了。他转过身的原因是他失控了。他失控了。然后摄像机切走了，所以你看不到。卡瑞尔疯了。我捂住脸，因为我在笑。我想，好吧，希望这能说明安吉拉·马丁不想看到它
laughing. The reason he turned away was because he lost it. He lost it. And then the camera cuts so you can't see it. Correll's insane. I covered my face because I was laughing. And I thought, okay, hopefully this tracks that Angela Martin wouldn't want to see it
因为我在笑，我不想毁了这一刻。天哪。离我们最近的，或者最近的之一。她就在那里。好吧，奥斯卡，我不知道你是否记得，但你和我一起接受采访。天哪，我不知道我们在哪里。我们正在为NBC做新闻发布会，有人问你关于那一刻的事，我永远不会忘记
because I'm laughing and I don't want to ruin this moment. Oh my God. The closest to us or one of the closest. She was like right there. Well, Oscar, I don't know if you remember, but you and I were doing an interview together. Oh my gosh, I don't know where we were. We were doing a press junket for NBC and someone asked you about the moment and I'll never forget
因为我记得，我记得是因为你骂人了，我当时想，我知道我们在摄像机前，但你说了一些类似“然后突然史蒂夫一直靠近，我当时想，该死的，他要亲我了”。你当时有那一刻，你知道已经过了不归点，它正在发生。好吧，史蒂夫太棒了，因为当他在片场想出那些即兴表演时，我觉得我有很多记忆
because I remember I remember it because you cursed and I was like, I know we're on camera, but you said something like then all of a sudden Steve keeps coming closer and I'm like, son of a bitch, he's gonna kiss me. That you had this moment where you knew it was past the point of no return, it's happening. Well, Steve was amazing because when he would come up with those improvs on set, I feel like I have a lot of memories
这是最普遍的一个，但只是关于他的记忆，你看到他有了个主意，但他是一个慢热处理主意的专家。是的。他，我看到他，当他说“我希望你们把这个刻在脑子里”时。我知道，天哪，他有一个主意，但他让我等，他让我们所有人都等。这就是他喜剧时机的天才之处。
and this is the one that is like most prevalent, but just the memory of him, you see him get an idea, but then he is a master at slow playing the idea. Yeah. He, I saw him as soon as he said, I want you to burn this into your brains. I knew, oh my gosh, he's has an idea, but he made me wait for it and he made all of us wait for it. And that is the genius of his comic timing.
对于迈克尔·斯科特来说，尽管这很荒谬，但在他看来，这是一件非常勇敢的事情。迈克尔·斯科特，他就像，他是英雄，对吧？是的。他就像，看我做了什么。看我做了什么。不，没有其他人能做到这一点。这就是为什么我有这个马克杯。
For Michael Scott, even though it's ass backwards, it was a very brave thing of him to do in his mind. Michael Scott, he's like, he was the hero, right? Yeah. He's like, look what I did. Look what I did. No, no one else could have done this. That's why I have the mug.
世界最佳老板。看我做了什么。然后珍娜，我有一个问题，因为我很确定我记得很清楚，但你有剧本。当雷恩作为德怀特插话去亲吻他时，雷恩即兴发挥了。哦，是的。那是完全即兴的。我只是喜欢那是德怀特想要参与进来的按钮。
World's best boss. Look what I did. And then Jenna, I have a question because I am pretty sure I remember this correctly, but you have the script. When Rain as Dwight then chimes in to kiss him, Rain improvised that. Oh yeah. That was totally improvised. And I just love that that's the button that Dwight's like, I'm going to get in here.
那是他的MO。这很贴切。他经常这样做。他只是没在那一幕里做。迈克尔会做某事。然后他会受到启发，说，我要做我老板正在做的事。但迈克尔说，不，不，德怀特，德怀特，别。
That's his MO. That's apropos. He did that a lot. He just didn't do it in that scene. Michael would do something. And then he would get inspired and go, I'm going to do what my boss is doing. But Michael said, no, no, Dwight, Dwight, don't.
因为那只是为了他。你可以看到雷恩在那里有点笑场。在他试图亲吻你之后，你看到了一点微笑。我向你们所有人致敬，因为那是一个荒谬的时刻。他退后说，我们做到了，我们还在这里。我们仍然，我们做到了，大家。什么？把他拖进这件事里。
Because it was just for him. You can see Rain break a little bit there. After he tries to kiss you, you see a little bit of a smile. I tip my hat to all you guys because that was a ridiculous moment. And for him to pull back and say, we did it, we're still here. We're still, we did it, everyone. What? Dragging everyone in with him to this thing.
我写了18分56秒。我写道，我想奥斯卡快要笑场了。那是我捕捉到的时刻。所以我打算回去看看是不是
I wrote it 18 minutes, 56 seconds. I wrote, I think Oscar's about to break right here. That's the moment I caught. So I'm going to go back and see if break right here. That's the moment I caught. So I'm gonna go back and see if it's your weird stomach grunt moment. That was the probably the most documentary moment of our fake documentary. That and when we sang goodbye to Steve.
你那奇怪的胃部咕哝时刻。那可能是我们伪纪录片中最具纪录片风格的时刻。那个，还有当我们向史蒂夫唱再见的时候。
Oh my gosh. Because remember Steve didn't know. No. Okay, Oscar, before you go, I wanna ask you this fan question. So as a result of Michael's behavior, Oscar ends up accepting a settlement with corporate and it includes this three-month paid leave and he says he and Gill are going to go to Europe.
天哪。因为记得史蒂夫不知道。不。好吧，奥斯卡，在你走之前，我想问你这个粉丝问题。所以由于迈克尔的行为，奥斯卡最终接受了与公司的和解，其中包括三个月的带薪假，他说他和吉尔要去欧洲。
So, Melinda Magger-Kirth and Mike McCarthy wrote in to ask this, when the character of Oscar goes on his three-month sabbatical, what was the real Oscar up to in real life during those three months? This comes under the umbrella of having two wonderful mentions as your bosses. I, when it rains it pours you guys, and while I was on the office, I pitched a show at Comedy Central and they said yes. It was an improvised show, which the aforementioned Damon Jones. Damon Jones, who was in the running for being the lead, is my buddy and he was executive producer of the show. We created it together and this other fellow, Kevin Ruff, we sold the show to Comedy Central
Melinda Magger-Kirth和Mike McCarthy写信问，当Oscar这个角色去休三个月长假时，现实生活中的Oscar那三个月在做什么？这属于那种有两位很棒的老板的情况。当时真是祸不单行，我在拍《办公室》的时候，向喜剧中心频道推销了一个节目，他们同意了。那是一个即兴表演节目，前面提到的Damon Jones也参与了。Damon Jones曾是主角候选人，他是我的好朋友，也是该节目的执行制片人。我们一起创作了这个节目，还有另一位叫Kevin Ruff的人，我们把节目卖给了喜剧中心。
and they said we want to do a season of it. And I'm like, oh, well, okay, but I'm on the office. But whatever, we'll figure it out. One day I was walking across, just to give you a little more glimpse into Steve and his thinking, he was walking across the, where outside on the asphalt, where all the cars are parked, the parking lot, it's called Oscar, the parking lot. And all our trailers are there.
他们说想拍一季。我说，哦，好吧，但我还在拍《办公室》。不过没关系，我们会想办法的。有一天我走在外面，为了让你更了解Steve和他的想法，他走在外面沥青路面上，就是所有车停的地方，停车场，那个停车场叫Oscar。我们所有的拖车都在那里。
And I caught up to him like, Steve, hey, what's up? I said, Steve, I was just offered to do a show at Comedy Central, but I love it here. What should I do? And he goes, Oscar, say yes to everything. Let your people figure it out. Let your manager and agent figure it out. That's not your job. You say yes to everything that they offer you.
我追上他说，Steve，嘿，怎么了？我说，Steve，我刚接到邀请去喜剧中心做一个节目，但我很喜欢这里。我该怎么办？他说，Oscar，对所有事情都说好。让你的人去解决。让你的经理和经纪人去解决。那不是你的工作。他们提供给你的所有东西，你都要说好。
Don't worry about anything else. Say yes, people will figure it out. So I said yes and I told Greg Daniels and he Say yes, people will figure it out. So I said yes, and I told Greg Daniels, and he's like, we'll figure it out, and they did. And this was my out. They gave me a beautiful, organic, seamless way out. So I was shooting a show. I was shooting 10 episodes of a show called,
别担心其他任何事。说好，人们会解决的。所以我说了好，我告诉了Greg Daniels，他说，我们会解决的，他们确实做到了。这就是我的出路。他们给了我一个完美、自然、无缝的退出方式。所以我去拍了一个节目。我拍了10集一个叫
Halfway Home, it was all improvised on Comedy Central. It was so good, Oscar. Thank you. It was so good, and so many of the people that we knew from the Groundlings and Improv Olympic were part of it. And you know who else? Octavia Spencer. How did she go on to do after that?
《Halfway Home》的节目，在喜剧中心频道全即兴表演。太棒了，Oscar。谢谢。真的太棒了，我们从Groundlings和Improv Olympic认识的很多人都参与了。你还知道谁吗？Octavia Spencer。那之后她发展得怎么样？
I think she did OK for herself. So Octavia was with us on that show. Many people went there. And Steve Pearce. Oh, so many people. Anyway, that's what I was doing. I went to do a show, shot 10 episodes, and then came back and folded right back into the office
我想她发展得不错。所以Octavia和我们一起拍了那个节目。很多人都去了那里。还有Steve Pearce。哦，好多人。总之，这就是我当时在做的事。我去拍了一个节目，拍了10集，然后回来，又重新融入了《办公室》
because of Greg Daniels, because of Steve Carell and Silverman and all those people. But you know, I think what people should know is that that is very unique, I feel like, to Greg. Absolutely. Because Greg was such a collaborator with us. And I know I had things throughout the nine year run, and I know Jenna, you did too,
多亏了Greg Daniels，多亏了Steve Carell和Silverman以及所有那些人。但你知道，我认为人们应该知道的是，我觉得这对于Greg来说是非常独特的。绝对是。因为Greg和我们合作得非常好。我知道在九年的拍摄过程中，我遇到过一些事情，我知道Jenna，你也遇到过，
where we had to go to them and say, hey, we got this opportunity. Will we be able to make it work? And he was always pro making it work and figuring it out. So how like amazingly gracious that he made this window for you to go shoot that show. It's not like, I'll do it, I'll have that opportunity later.
我们不得不去找他们说，嘿，我们有这个机会。我们能协调好吗？他总是支持我们去协调并解决问题。所以他为你腾出时间去拍那个节目真是太慷慨了。并不是说，我会做的，我以后会有那个机会的。
This is important. And he knew, he knows that it's important to get a pitch meeting. It's important to, I'll do it, I'll have that opportunity later. This is important and he knew, he knows that. It's important to get a pitch meeting. It's important to just sell a show. This doesn't happen every day. We're all, you know, we're all mature. Am I younger than Angela and Jenna by 15, 20 years? Yes, but that's not the point. We're all, we're all mature people.
这很重要。他知道，他知道获得推销会议的机会很重要。获得推销节目的机会很重要。这不会每天都发生。我们都是，你知道，我们都是成熟的人。我比Angela和Jenna小15、20岁吗？是的，但重点不是这个。我们都是成熟的人。
We're all mature people. Oh. Well, you had, you had pitched it and created it. It was your baby. That's right. And you got to go do it. And then you got pitched it and created it. It was your baby. That's right. You got to go do it. And then you got to come back to the office. You guys, if I had to choose,
我们都是成熟的人。哦。好吧，你推销并创作了它。那是你的心血结晶。没错。你得去完成它。然后你又回到了《办公室》。伙计们，如果我必须选择，
I don't know what I would have done because of Bert in the hand. Yeah. And I knew the, so I would have had to say no to a show. I, you know, I might've said no to a comedy. I probably would have said no to that. And that would have been horrible. Yeah.
我不知道我会怎么做，因为鸟在手中。是的。我知道，所以我可能不得不拒绝那个节目。我，你知道，我可能拒绝了一部喜剧。我可能真的会拒绝它。那会很糟糕。是的。
So I got to do both. I got to do both. You got to do both. And as Michael would say, it was a win, win, win. That's right. Very nicely done, Angela. Oscar, thank you so much. My pleasure. You're awesome. This was so nice.
所以我两样都做了。我两样都做了。你两样都做了。正如Michael所说，这是一个三赢的局面。没错。做得很好，Angela。Oscar，非常感谢。不客气。你太棒了。这真是太好了。
My pleasure. Love you, Angela. Love you, Jenna. Love you, Oscar. Bye. Bye! Bye! You've got unlimited access to music, but time, now that's limited. The PC Insider's World's Elite Mastercard gets you unlimited PC Optima points, free grocery delivery, and time back for what matters. Save time and earn $1,100 in average value each year. The PC Insider's World Elite MasterCard. The card for living unlimited.
不客气。爱你，Angela。爱你，Jenna。爱你，Oscar。再见。再见！再见！你可以无限使用音乐，但时间是有限的。PC Insider's World's Elite Mastercard为你提供无限的PC Optima积分、免费送货服务，并为你节省时间。每年平均节省时间并获得1100美元的价值。PC Insider's World Elite Mastercard。为无限生活而生的卡片。
Conditions apply to all benefits. Visit pcfinancial.ca for details. Value is for illustrative purposes only. Spring is here, and you can now get almost anything you need delivered with Uber Eats. What do we mean by almost? You can't get a well-groomed lawn delivered, but you can get chicken Parmesan delivered.
所有福利均受条件限制。详情请访问pcfinancial.ca。价值仅供参考。春天到了，你现在可以通过Uber Eats配送几乎任何你需要的东西。我们说的“几乎”是什么意思？你不能配送修剪整齐的草坪，但你可以配送鸡肉帕尔马干酪。
Sunshine? No. Some wine? Yes. Get almost, almost anything delivered with Uber Eats. Order now. Alcohol in select markets. See app for details. All right. Oh my gosh. Oh my gosh.
阳光？不行。一些葡萄酒？可以。通过Uber Eats配送几乎任何东西。立即订购。酒精饮料仅在特定市场提供。详情请查看应用程序。好的。天哪。天哪。
Wasn't that amazing? He's hilarious. That was amazing. I love him so much. I love him so much. Now there's not that much more to talk about, but there are a couple little things before we wrap things up. I wanna talk about Jim in the conference room.
那不是很棒吗？他太搞笑了。那太棒了。我非常爱他。我非常爱他。现在没剩下多少要谈的了，但在结束之前还有几件小事。我想谈谈会议室里的Jim。
Fancy Stanford conference room. Yes, and he's having his diversity training. And guys, Larry Wilmore. Larry Wilmore came back. Back again is Mr. Brown. Yes. Hero, acronym hero, it's all there. You might notice that Jim has an empty chair next to him
高级的斯坦福会议室。是的，他正在进行多元化培训。伙计们，Larry Wilmore。Larry Wilmore回来了。Mr. Brown又回来了。是的。英雄，缩写HERO，都在那里。你可能会注意到Jim旁边有一个空椅子
and he kind of looks wistfully at the chair. This is a nod to that moment in the previous diversity day where Pam fell asleep on his shoulder. It was kind of their first moment of connection, their first moment of physical connection and he's remembering that. yeah they're both missing each other. they're missing each other. they are. and now back at dunder mifflin, dwight gets a package. he gets a package from jim. it's a gaydar detector. it looks
他若有所思地看着那把椅子。这是对之前多元化日Pam在他肩膀上睡着那一刻的致敬。那是他们第一次产生联系的时刻，他们第一次身体接触的时刻，他正在回忆那个。是的，他们都在想念对方。他们在想念对方。他们是。现在回到Dunder Mifflin，Dwight收到一个包裹。他收到了Jim寄来的包裹。是一个“同志雷达”探测器。它看起来
like a little mini vacuum but it's probably just a metal detector, right? It literally is a metal detector. I texted Phil Shea about it and it is a repurposed metal detector, which makes total sense because it beeps when it goes across Oscar's belt. His belt. They all wore belts, guys. And so then of course it beeps when it goes across Dwight's belt. Oh, and then who has a little smile? A little wistful smile?
像一个小型的真空吸尘器，但它可能只是一个金属探测器，对吧？它确实就是一个金属探测器。我给Phil Shea发短信问过，它是一个重新利用的金属探测器，这很有道理，因为它在扫过Oscar的皮带时会发出哔哔声。他的皮带。伙计们，他们都戴着皮带。所以当它扫过Dwight的皮带时，它当然会发出哔哔声。哦，然后谁露出了微笑？一个若有所思的微笑？
Mm-hmm. Pam. That Jim, she's thinking. She's thinking, oh, that Jim. He did a prank all the way from Fancy Stanford. Yeah. I know. And he doesn't know that I have an apartment now and I'm eating frozen food because I canceled my wedding. And I'm going, I have art classes. I enrolled in art classes like he said I should. I know. I'm actually glad that Jim went to Stanford and that he doesn't know this about Pam because I think it's really important that Pam has her own
嗯哼。Pam。那个Jim，她在想。她在想，哦，那个Jim。他从高级的斯坦福远道而来搞了个恶作剧。是的。我知道。而且他不知道我现在有公寓了，因为我取消了婚礼，我正在吃冷冻食品。而且我正在去上艺术课。我报名参加了艺术课，就像他建议的那样。我知道。我其实很高兴Jim去了斯坦福，而且他不知道Pam的这些事，因为我觉得Pam有她自己的
journey. Well, I think one of the reasons why Pam and Jim were able to get together in the end was because she had this time between relationships. Yes. She had this time alone. She's been with Roy for over a decade I think when we talk about it. Yeah. Maybe not that long but since high school. Pam. I mean, they live together. She needs this alone time. I think it's good. It's good for them. We know it's all going to work out in the end. They don't know that yet, but this is the right thing. Kids, kids, kids, don't go from one relationship to the next. Okay. Figure out how you are. Figure out how you are. Between how you are between okay what
旅程非常重要。嗯，我认为Pam和Jim最终能在一起的原因之一是她在两段关系之间有这段时间。是的。她有这段独处的时间。当我们谈论它时，我想她和Roy在一起超过十年了。是的。也许没那么久，但从高中开始就是了。Pam。我的意思是，他们住在一起。她需要这段独处时间。我认为这很好。这对他们有好处。我们知道最终一切都会好起来的。他们还不知道，但这确实是正确的事情。孩子们，孩子们，孩子们，不要从一段关系直接跳到下一段。好的。弄清楚你是谁。弄清楚你是谁。在……之间，你是谁，好的，什么
are these accents we're doing I don't know women I don't know I doubt your bossy aunt that's bossy aunt accent all right you guys that was gay witch hunt thanks so much for listening in if we missed anything write us because you know we like it you know we like it. And next week we're gonna talk about the convention. Yes. All right, we'll see you next week. See you then. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' Second Drink.
我们在模仿什么口音？我不知道，女人，我不知道，我怀疑是你的专横阿姨，那是专横阿姨的口音。好了，伙计们，这就是“同志猎巫行动”，非常感谢你们的收听，如果我们漏掉了什么，写信告诉我们，因为你知道我们喜欢这样，你知道我们喜欢这样。下周我们将讨论“大会”。是的。好的，我们下周见。到时候见。感谢收听Office Ladies的第二杯。
This episode was initially created in collaboration with Earwulf. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins and our audio engineer and associate producer is Daniella Silva. Odyssey's executive producers are Jenna Weiss-Berman and Leah Reese-Dennis. Office Ladies is mixed and mastered by Chris Basil. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
本集最初是与Earwulf合作制作的。Office Ladies是Odyssey的节目，由Jenna Fisher和Angela Kinsey制作。我们的执行制片人是Cassie Jerkins，我们的音频工程师和副制片人是Daniella Silva。Odyssey的执行制片人是Jenna Weiss-Berman和Leah Reese-Dennis。Office Ladies由Chris Basil混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是Creed Bratton的《Rubber Tree》。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。